[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur public sénat pour suivre ce nouveau
numéro des matins du sénat les missions
qui vous fait vivre les travaux des
sénateurs vous allez suivre dans un
instant l'audition d'elisabeth moreno
ministre chargée de l'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes de la diversité
également de l'égalité des chances
elisabeth moreno vient du secteur privé
elle été nommée au gouvernement à l'été
dernier et ce matin elle se présente
devant la délégation des droits des
femmes du sénat pour et bien expliquer
le plan d'action de son ministère je
vous laisse écouter cette audition pour
2021 à destination des auteurs de
violence appelle quelques précisions ces
moyens sont ils destinés au financement
de l'hébergement des violons conjugaux
et à celui de la plate forme
téléphonique gérée par la fnaca nous
avons auditionné l'un de ses principaux
acteurs pendant le confinement
d'ailleurs et ça faisait partie de votre
actualité sur lci je crois ce matin
pouvez-vous nous assurer que les crédits
consacrés actions des conjoints violents
ne se traduiront pas par une baisse des
moyens qui demeure indispensable
d'affecter à l'hébergement d'urgence des
femmes victimes de violences par
ailleurs nos préoccupations concernent
aussi l'annoncent d'une mise en
concurrence de la fnsf pour
l'attribution du numéro d'urgence 39,19
que cette association a pourtant créé
pouvez vous nous dire madame la ministre
plus sur les motivations juridique de ce
marché public qui suscite à juste titre
beaucoup d'émotion dans le milieu
associatif
enfin l'axé ali g avait suscité beaucoup
d'interrogations pendant le premier
confinement au point d'avoir suscité des
amendements de notre collègue laurence
rossignol pour reporter le délai légal
de l'ibg à 14 semaines une proposition
de loi était adopté
tout récemment à l'assemblée nationale
dans cette même logique
à cet égard concernant ce nouveau
confinement quelles mesures ont été
prises pour que les femmes qui
souhaitent exercer ce droit dans les
semaines à venir puissent y accéder
je le rappelle souvent
vivez g doit être traité comme une
urgence merci madame la ministre je vous
sais de la parole est ensuite bien
entendu les collègues qui nous ont
rejoint d'ailleurs de nous sommes
beaucoup plus nombreux qu'eux au début
de l'audition donc pourront échanger
avec vous par visio merci à vous madame
la ministre
merci infiniment madame la présidente
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
bonjour je vous remercie d'abord
vivement pour votre invitation que le
confinement me contraint d'honorer
virtuellement mais je suis certaine que
la visioconférence nat elle n'altèrera
pas la qualité de nos échanges et
aujourd'hui j'ai rencontré notre
président il y a quelques semaines ainsi
que certains d'entre vous et je sais
l'importance de votre engagement et les
travaux menés par votre délégation sur
le sujet du droit des femmes sur les
enjeux importants qui sont les nôtres je
considère qu'il est tout à fait
essentiel que le parlement et le
gouvernement travaillent main dans la
main en bonne intelligence et en ayant
un dialogue à la fois francs est
toujours constructif
c'est la clé je pense de notre réussite
collective et c'est l'idée que je me
fais de la conduite de ma mission
alors au cours de mon propos liminaire
j'évoquerai tout d'abord l'actualité
brûlante à savoir le confinement et les
dispositifs qui ont été mis en place par
le gouvernement pour lutter contre les
violences conjugales que la promiscuité
a malheureusement tendance à aggraver et
puis ensuite je dresserai un bilan en
forme de point d'étape de ce qui a été
accompli par le gouvernement depuis 2017
et je vous exposerai en parallèle match
feuille de route pour les mois qui
viennent et je pense que cela répondra
madame la présidente aux questions que
vous avez évoquées dans votre propos
liminaires et évidemment je répondrai
ensuite à tous vos questions alors comme
vous le savez afin d'enrayer la
propagation du virus du colis de 19 le
président de la république a décidé la
semaine dernière de renouveler le
confinement mis en place au printemps
dernier et ce jusqu'au 1er décembre
et parce qu'il revient souvent à
emprisonner les victimes avec leurs
bourreaux dans un huis clos parfois un
peu étouffant le confinement constitue
un facteur aggravant en matière de
violence
très familial nous avons pu le constater
lors des premiers confinement et nous
avons donc pleinement conscience et nous
avons beaucoup appris de ce premier
confinement en étroite collaboration
avec les associations avec les
collectivités locales les élus avec nos
forces de l'ordre avec le secteur privé
aussi parfois le gouvernement a été
pleinement mobilisés durant cette
période tout à fait inédite pour
secourir protéger et accompagner les
femmes victimes de violences conjugales
par exemple les services de police sont
intervenus de façon systématique à
chaque signalement ce qui a permis un
meilleur repérage des violences et les
interventions à domicile dans la sphère
familiale ont ainsi augmenté de 42 %
pendant la période de confinement les
chattes de la plateforme
arrêtons les violences géré par le
ministère de l'intérieur ont également
été multipliée par quatre et la justice
n'est quant à elle absolument pas d'esp
est confiné bien au contraire puisque
350 auteurs de violence ont été déférés
et jugé pendant le premier confinement
et 129 téléphone grand danger ont été
distribués aux victimes
enfin malgré les conditions de travail
difficiles les lignes des coudes sont
restés tout à fait active et
opérationnelles pour vous parler du 39
19 que nous évoquerons tout à l'heure eh
bien les appels ont fortement augmenté
il y a eu 40 4235 appels entre le 16
mars et le 11 mai 2020 nous avons eu 158
situations de violences conjugales qui
ont été prises en charge via la
plateforme violence du sang 16 006 et
puis 140 dossiers par jour ont été reçus
au plus fort du confinement à travers le
dispositif du sms 114
en d'autres termes la continuité du
service public et associatif a pu être
assuré mais évidemment à contexte
exceptionnel il faut des moyens
exceptionnels et ses dispositifs
d'alerté d'urgence ont ainsi été
renforcés et diversifier pour s'adapter
à des circonstances tout à fait
particulière au delà des dispositifs
existants que vous connaissez déjà mais
sur lesquelles
sûre je reviendrai tout à l'heure des
mesures inédites ont été instaurées
qu'il s'agisse par exemple de la mise en
place des points d'accueil éphémère dans
les supermarchés où les centres
commerciaux pour permettre aux femmes
victimes de violence de se signaler et
de s'informer de manière plus
confidentielle ou alors le financement
exceptionnel de 20 neil nuitées d'hôtel
pour mettre les victimes à l'abri et les
éloigner de leur agresseur on a
également travaillé sur un dispositif
que nous avons appelée alerte pharmacie
qui permet aux victimes de violences
intrafamiliales ou au témoin amie annie
de se signaler auprès de leur pharmacien
afin qu'il prenne attache avec les
forces de l'ordre
et puis il ya eu également la création
d'un numéro d' écoute dédié aux auteurs
de violences afin de prévenir le passage
à l'acte ou encore la récidive
par ailleurs en raison du caractère
exceptionnel de cette période des moyens
financiers supplémentaires ont été
allouées aux associations afin qu'elles
puissent évidemment adapter leurs modes
de travail et continuer à venir en aide
aux victimes
et puis cinq cent mille euros ont été
consacrés à l'accueil d'urgence des
femmes et de leurs enfants l'art au
total ce sont 4 millions d'euros de
financements supplémentaires qui ont été
votés en loi de finances rectificative
pour soutenir l'ensemble des dispositifs
que je viens de vous exposer et je tiens
enfin à signaler que le nombreuses
initiatives locales ont vu le jour à la
faveur de ce confinement et des
initiatives mises en place par des
associations art des collectivités
locales par nos forces de l'ordre par
des services déconcentrés de l'état que
je veux aujourd'hui remercié devant vous
enfin on a mis en évidence un rapport
pardon la vie propre a mis en évidence
dans son rapport paru cet été que la
mobilisation des policiers des gendarmes
et des magistrats a été tout à fait
décisive pour protéger et accompagner
les femmes victimes de violences et
leurs enfants durant cette période et je
tiens encore une fois à reconnaître leur
travail devant nous
en fait l'engagement de l'état et des
associations a été totalement engagés
durant cette période et nous avons
appris de ce qui s'est passé et nous
allons reconduire ce que nous avons
appris alors la deuxième période de
confinement que nous vivons actuellement
doit de nouveau nous mobiliser et notre
vigilance doit redoubler parce que dès
vendredi dernier j'ai décidé en
prévision et par anticipation de ce qui
se passe est de réunir les associations
des droits des femmes avec pour objectif
de nous assurer de la continuité de
l'action des associations pendant cette
période mais également de nous assurer
de l'opérationnalité des dispositifs
existants en matière de lutte contre les
violences conjugales
et puis de voir si les dispositifs
nécessite des dispositifs
supplémentaires étaient nécessaires
et puis enfin évidemment pour écouter et
entendre les attentes des recueillir les
idées que les associations pouvaient
avoir à nous partager et j'ai l'intimé
conviction que c'est une bataille
collective que nous devons mener tous
ensemble pouvoirs publics et tissus
associatifs doivent absolument
travailler main dans la main et en toute
confiance et en toute transparence pour
enrayer ce fléau
le message que j'ai passé vendredi
dernier aux associations était simple je
voulais qu'elle sache que les le
gouvernement est je pense plus
particulièrement au ministère de
l'intérieur au ministère de la justice
au ministère de la santé ou encore du
logement était tout à fait déterminé est
entièrement mobilisé pour les
accompagner d'un point de vue
extrêmement concret nous allons
redéployer les mesures qui avaient été
mises en place au printemps dernier et
compte tenu de leur bilan positif nous
avons également décidé de maintenir les
dispositifs suivants le traitement
judiciaire des violences qui a été
priorisé le dispositif alerte pharmacie
la ligne d'écouté à destination des
auteurs de violences géré par la fnaca
ben est également pérenniser ainsi que
les points d'information dans les
centres commerciaux les points dits qu
éphémère dont je vous parle
tout à l'heure en plus de la
pérennisation de ces dispositifs nous
avons également mis en place tout
récemment un partenariat avec
l'entreprise hubert qui fournira 2000
trash air gratuits aux femmes victimes
de violences à travers le 39 19
ce jusqu'au 31 mars 2021 et à l'instar
du premier confinement nous apporterons
un soutien financier supplémentaire aux
associations afin qu'elles puissent
continuer à assurer correctement leur
mission
par ailleurs des l'organisation du
confinement
j'ai tenu à veiller à ce que aucune
attestation de déplacement de soin
nécessaire pour les femmes victimes de
violence qui souhaiteraient ou qui ont
besoin de fuir leurs voix et leurs
foyers enfin durant le premier
confinement le ministère de la santé a
assoupli les délai de sept à neuf
semaines d'aménorrhée pour liv et j'ai
médicamenteuse et il a mis en place des
téléconsultations afin de permettre aux
femmes d'avoir accès à ce droit en
pleine période de crise et nous allons
évidemment prolonger ses actions et puis
j'ai tenu à ce que notre ministère
communique très vite et très largement
sur les différents dispositifs que je
viens de vous exposer et nous
continuerons à le faire je compte
évidemment sur vous sur votre aide pour
les faire connaître le plus largement
possible
en d'autres termes je suis nous sommes
totalement mobilisés et l'ensemble des
différents dispositifs d'alerté et de
secours sont actifs et opérationnelles
pour écouter se courir et protéger les
personnes victimes de violences à
l'intérieur de leur foyer évidemment
vous le savez mais je veux le répéter la
lutte contre les violences faites aux
femmes est une priorité de chaque
instant et il n'est pas question que
nous baissions lagarde
surtout pendant cette période de
confinement alors au delà de l'actualité
qui nous occupe
permettez moi maintenant de faire le
point sur notre action plus globale en
matière d'égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes qui a été érigée comme vous
le savez en grande course du quinquennat
par le président de la république depuis
trois ans l'ensemble du gouvernement
s'est mobilisé au travers d'une
stratégie interne
derrière qui est à la fois forte et
ambitieuse cet engagement sans précédent
s'est matérialisé par plusieurs choses
la tenue du comité interministériel à
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
le 8 mars 2018
le vote de trois lois la tenue du
grenelle pour violences conjugales lancé
par le premier ministre edouard philippe
et ma prédécesseure le 3 septembre 2010
où il y avait présent quinze autres
ministres nous avons et si vous me le
permettez pardon je vais m'attarder sur
le grenelle il a été le fruit d'un
travail inédit de concertation des
principaux acteurs concernés par ce
sujet les associations les élus les
experts ou encore les familles des
victimes et les victimes elles mêmes et
c'est un travail qui a permis de mettre
la lumière sur un sujet trop longtemps
resté dans l'ombre et à son issue
quarante six mesures ont été annoncées
des mesures fortes des mesures concrètes
pour faire diminuer le nombre de
féminicide et pour lutter toujours plus
contre les violences faites aux femmes
dès le 3 septembre dernier avec les 11
groupes de travail du grenelle
j'ai souhaité réaliser un point d'étape
de ce travail important
nous avons plusieurs objectifs dans
cette réunion c'est d'identifier ce qui
a été fonctionnaire et que ce qui a pu
fonctionner correctement d'identifier
ceux qui restent en cours d'exécution ou
de conception
et puis de déceler les points de blocage
qui ont pu advenir
durant ces douze mois alors où est ce
que nous en sommes aujourd'hui
les dix mesures d'urgence ont toutes été
réalisées et au total 50 % des mesures
du grenelle ont été mises en oeuvre
vingt mesures sont encore en cours de
réalisation et trois mesures sont encore
en construction
si beaucoup de chemin reste encore à
parcourir
nous pouvons nous féliciter de ce
résultat qui est évidemment en
progression et permettez-moi d'énumérer
quelques unes de ses mesures que nous
avons récemment mis en place
alors nous avons seize centres de prise
en charge et d'accompagnement des
auteurs de violences
qui vont voir le jour dès la fin de
cette année sur l'ensemble du territoire
national et trois de ces mesures seront
sur le territoire outre mer a comme à
cayenne à cayenne pardon à fort de
france ou à saint paul et celle entre
proposeront aux auteurs de violences
conjugales un accompagnement à la fois
psychothérapeutique et médical afin par
exemple de traiter les addictions
c'est une revendication forte et
importante des victimes et des
associations qui est issu de ce grenelle
et nous sommes heureux de la concrétiser
parce qu'il s'agit d'une avancée
significative est extrêmement concrètes
dans la prévention du passage à l'acte
est évidemment de la récidive
le financement de ces seize centres
s'élèvera à 1 million d'euros et il sera
assuré par les crédits de la loi de
finances rectificative 2020 un deuxième
appel à projets aura lieu en début 2021
avec pour objectif une couverture
territoriale beaucoup plus large je
pense également bien sûr au bracelet
anti rapprochement qui ont été déployés
le 5 septembre en septembre dernier dans
cinq juridictions et nous espérons
passer à 38 réduction d'ici la fin du
mois de novembre et ses bracelets seront
évidemment généralisé sur l'ensemble du
territoire d'ici la fin de cette année
parmi les mesures en cours de
déploiement je souhaiterais également
cité les unités médico judiciaires qui
permettent aux femmes de porter plainte
directement dans les hôpitaux
trente d'entre elles sont déjà en place
j'ai eu l'occasion d'en visiter et je
peux vous dire que ce dispositif
fonctionne parfaitement bien et qu'ils
répondent aux besoins des victimes des
violences
par ailleurs nous comptons également
créer 1000 places d'hébergement
supplémentaires pour accueillir les
victimes en 2021
et puis c'est un engagement que
emmanuelle wargon et moi avons pris et
que nous et qui nous tient très à coeur
parce que l'éloignement des victimes de
leur foyer lorsque c'est nécessaire et
très important en somme je veux que nous
adoptions en matière de lutte contre les
violences conjugales une véritable
culture du résultat
nous sommes extrêmement attendu sur ce
sujet et nous devons être à la hauteur
de ses attentes
c'est pourquoi je réunirai toutes les
six semaines les 11 groupes de travail
du grenelle afin développer des points
d'étape régulier je l' ai déjà fait à
deux reprises depuis ma prise de
fonction la première fois le 3 septembre
dernier et la dernière fois le 13
octobre
et je serais ravi évidemment d'y
associer les parlementaires qui
souhaitent nous rejoindre
d'ailleurs madame la présidente nous a
fait l'honneur de sa présence le 13
octobre dernier je l'en remercie encore
mon objectif est bien sûr de m'assurer
de l'exécution rigoureuse de l'ensemble
des mesures du grenelle et dans ce cadre
permettez moi de m'arrêter encore sur le
39 19 vous l'avez évoqué tout à l'heure
mais la présidente j'ai entendu vos
préoccupations à ce sujet à l'occasion
du grenelle
le gouvernement s'est fixé l'objectif
ambitieux d'avoir une plate forme
téléphonique qui soit disponible 24
heures sur 24 et 7 jours sur 7
il s'agit d'une demande des victimes et
des associations notamment en raison des
difficultés qu'elles sont rencontrés sur
les territoires ultramarins et pour les
personnes en situation de handicap ou
les personnes malentendantes ou
aphasiques et nous devons répondre à
cette demande
l'état entend ainsi faire de la
plateforme téléphonique d'écouté
d'orientation des victimes des violences
conjugales un véritable service public
et devant vous je tiens à saluer avec
force
l'action remarquable que la fnsf à plus
assurée en termes d'écouté des victimes
et c'est une action soutenue et
accompagnée depuis sa création
néanmoins le cadre juridique nécessite
de passer par la commande publique parce
que l'état est à l'initiative de ce
service est il le financera à hauteur de
100%
comme vous pouvez l'imaginer cette
procédure est strictement encadrée par
le droit des marchés publics et elle
garantira la qualité d
j'ai présenté pour renforcer l'écouté
l'accompagnement des victimes de
violences conjugales
les candidats qui se présenteront
devront évidemment se conformer à un
cahier des charges extrêmement exigeants
qui est en cours de rédaction et qui
sera publié d'ici la fin de cette année
compte tenu des délais juridiques
nécessaires la déduplication du marché
public ne pourra avoir lieu au printemps
croyez bien comme ministère et ses
services seront particulièrement
attentifs à la qualité des projets qui
nous seront présentés je pense notamment
à la formation des écoutantes et des
écoutants en matière de violence afin de
renforcer l'écouté l'accompagnement des
victimes de violences conjugales
la lutte contre les violences sexistes
et sexuelles reste et restera une
priorité de notre gouvernement
c'est une priorité avec un niveau
d'exigence et des ambitions très élevées
une priorité parce que des vies humaines
sont en jeu
c'est une priorité aussi parce que
l'état en synergie avec les associations
l'ensemble des élus mais également les
forces de l'ordre les entreprises et les
partenaires sociaux a les moyens d'agir
et qu'il se doit d'être au rendez vous
parce que ces violences ne sont pas une
fatalité
depuis trois ans nous avons été
pleinement mobilisés et nous le
resterons plus que jamais jusqu'à la fin
de ce quinquennat et bien sûr pour agile
pour conduire cette politique publique
volontariste
il nous faut des moyens j'en viens donc
à la question du budget dédié à
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
c'est une question tout à fait central
qui je le sais suscite parfois des
interrogations ou cristallise les
critiques à ses interrogations et ses
critiques sont compréhensibles tant les
enjeux sont importants et parce que je
sais que le sénat est votre délégation
sont très attentifs à cette question je
voudrais vous apporter plusieurs
éléments de précisions les crédits du
programme 135 et plus largement ceux
affectés à la lutte contre les violences
faites aux femmes sont en nette
progression
le programme 100
27 qui est piloté par notre ministère
atteint en loi de finances initiale
la barre de 29,7 millions d'euros dès
2017 et pour 2021
comme vous le savez il a atteint 41,5
millions d'euros il s'agit d'une
progression remarquable de 40%
c'est une progression qui a été voté
lundi soir par les députés lors de
l'examen en séance publique du projet de
loi de finances pour 2021 et je m'en
réjouis
et c'est l'un des premiers dossiers que
j'ai menées lors de ma prise de fonction
et je crois qu'on peut dire que c'est
une hausse historique que l'on peut
mettre au crédit de ce gouvernement
cette augmentation de crédit va être
utilisé vers niveau et je voudrais vous
partager tout d'abord nous voulons
financer les dispositifs très attendu
que j'évoquais tout à l'heure et qui
vont concrétiser la pleine mise en
oeuvre des engagements du grenelle à
savoir les centres de prise en charge
des auteurs de violences ou encore
l'extension de la plate forme
téléphonique 39 19 nous voulons
également dans un deuxième lieu à
croître les budgets disponibles pour le
travail pour aider le travail des
associations
et puis en troisième lieu nous
souhaitons augmenter la part du budget
alloué aux actions en faveur de
l'égalité professionnelle
comme nous le savons tous le budget
consacré aux violences faites aux femmes
ne se concentre pas que sur le programme
137 et d'ailleurs ils en représentent
j'ai presque envie de dire une faible
part de nombreuses
de nombreux autres programmes
budgétaires et concours parfois très
fortement
je pense notamment au ministère de
l'intérieur au ministère de l'éducation
nationale de la justice de la santé ou
encore du logement qui y consacrent
d'importants moyens
aussi depuis 2010 cette grâce aux
travaux interministériels nous avons
réussi à améliorer l'évaluation globale
de ces crédits comme le montre
l'augmentation des crédits figurant dans
le cadre du dpt c'est d'un document qui
joue le concède pourrait gagner en
lisibilité en rigueur et en méthodologie
notamment pour pouvoir réaliser des
comparaisons pertinentes et mieux mettre
en lumière
la réalité des politiques que nous
finançons et pour l'exercice 2010 21 le
périmètre d'évacuation est passé à 46
programme contre 39 en 2020 et 32 en
2019 mais aussi et surtout le dpt
égalité 2021 comporte un nombre
sensiblement plus élevé de programmes
qui concourent à sa réelle rédaction
notamment pour sa partie budgétaire soit
28 programmes au lieu les 18 de 2021
nous améliorons donc sensiblement cette
lisibilité des politiques d'égalité et
ce sont des efforts à poursuivre avec
tous les ministères concernés qu'ils
nous fournissent les données nécessaires
pour alimenter notre dpt mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
le gouvernement s'est fixé pour ambition
de réduire l'ensemble des formes
d'inégalité entre les femmes et les
hommes
et cet objectif constitue l'une des
priorités de notre feuille de route
c'est donc l'occasion pour moi d'aborder
ici la question des pensions
alimentaires en france
aujourd'hui nous comptons 2,4 millions
de familles monoparentales 85% de ces
familles sont composés d'une femme avec
leurs enfants et sept cent mille d'entre
elles vivent sous le seuil de pauvreté
le non paiement des pensions
alimentaires par les pairs assigne donc
les mères et leurs enfants a une grande
précarité et cette prise en otage
financière est tout simplement
inacceptable
c'est pourquoi avec olivier ferrand nous
avons mis en place dès cet automne le
paiement direct des pensions
alimentaires par les caisses
d'allocations familiales
il s'agit là d'un enjeu de justice
sociale et de lutte contre la pauvreté
je voudrais également vous partagez
cette mesure forte qu'a annoncé le
président de la république le mois
dernier et que nous allons mettre en
oeuvre avec adrien taquet l'allongement
du congé paternité
il s'agit là encore d'une mesure
essentielle non seulement dans l'intérêt
des enfants mais également des deux
parents
c'est une mesure qui permettra de
favoriser l'égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes dans le travail ainsi qu'au
sein de la famille l'allongement du
congé paternité permettra je pense un
meilleur équilibre au bénéfice de
l'ensemble de la famille en conclusion
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs ont
obtenu du temps qui m'est imparti je
n'ai malheureusement pas pu être
exhaustive sur l'étendue des missions
qui sont les miennes je vous ai
néanmoins j'espère présenté les grandes
lignes du bilan de l'action du
gouvernement et de la feuille de route
du ministère qin a été confiée par le
président de la république et par le
premier ministre vous l'aurez compris
mon ministère sera celui de l'action et
je veux être une ministre pragmatique
focaliser sur des actions concrètes et
concentré sur les résultats pour mener
les multiples combats qui sont les miens
désormais j'aurai besoin de vous parce
que je crois profondément en
l'intelligence collective
je sais le travail important réalisé par
le sénat et par votre délégation ces
dernières années vous jouez je le sais
aussi un double rôle d'aiguillon et de
vigie et je crois qu'une démocratie plus
efficace est une démocratie fondée sur
le dialogue et sur la propre
construction et c'est ainsi que je
conçois ma mission et c'est évidemment
ce qui donnera tout le sens à ce que
nous entreprenons avec détermination et
ce que nous entreprendrons encore
pendant les 500 jours à venir je vous
remercie pour votre attention
merci madame la ministre déjà merci pour
votre engagement et la volonté que vous
affichez ce matin vraiment importante
donc les collègues nous ont rejoints
nombreux à cette audition que ce soit
par visio et en présence également
donc ils vont vous poser différentes
questions même si vous avez apporté
d'ores et déjà beaucoup de réponses
moi j'aurais juste peut-être une petite
question par rapport aux différents
crédits qui ont été adoptées par le
parlement
au cours des des projets de loi de
finances rectificatif par rapport à leur
attribution parce que c'est bien de
voter des crédits mais c'est encore
mieux de les attribuer de savoir si les
critères d'attribution à la fois les
deux demandes d'appel à projets et des
dossiers parfois un petit peu complexe
et cartes des associations extrêmement
présente est utile dans nos départements
j'en veux pour preuve les réductions et
qui ont été annoncées par exemple à sos
femmes vendaient des l'annnonce du
confinement en terme de deux
possibilités de de service vis-à-vis des
femmes victimes de violences une
deuxième chose j'ai fait une visite dans
un centre qui pratique privée jai à
fontenay-le-comte en vendée excusez moi
mais ces messieurs les sénateurs et
mesdames est le constat qui a été fait
au cours du premier confinement c'est
que certains centres qui pratiquer les
ivg ont carrément fermé leurs activités
et donc il y avait un centre qui
récupère est tout les toutes les
demandes dit vg donc bien entendu les
demandes urgentes étaient encore plus
difficiles à traiter
et lorsqu'on on parle moi je salue tout
votre engagement et les dispositions qui
ont été prises pour ce deuxième
confinement avec la poursuite des des
bonnes idées qui avait été mis en place
il faut le reconnaître la première fois
sachez que lorsqu'on sera dans le
département de l'yonne ou dans le
département de la vienne ou dans le
département de la vendée
il sera difficile de recourir à un des
deux mille trajet en neuf heures pour
regagner un centre d'hébergement voilà
donc les les gars sont très compliqué à
traiter mais je vais tout de suite passé
la parole également à mes collègues qui
l'ont demandé je salue aussi votre
engagement vis-à-vis de des territoires
outre-mer
parce que c'est vrai que les les
conditions de confinement sont encore
différente dans ces territoires
et je vois que notre collègue victoire
j'espère d'ailleurs s'est inscrite pour
vous sollicitez donc la première à
demander la parole c'était madame darcos
et ensuite ce sera madame filleul
on va prendre deux par deux si vous le
souhaitez voilà bonjour madame la
ministre je vous remercie en tout cas en
effet pour votre enthousiasme comme
notre présidente
et surtout votre volonté de travailler
avec nous ça n'a pas toujours été le cas
et je dois dire que nous en sommes
vraiment touchés parce que je pense que
sur chacun d'eux j'allais dire de nos
bancs fin à cette délégation on a un
travail vraiment en commun bien au-delà
de nos appartenances politiques on est
toujours on est vraiment pour la plupart
des décisions d'accord entre nous et
c'est une vraie volonté de travailler
pour cette égalité homme femme
je voulais juste revenir deux minutes
sur sur budget parce que le problème
c'est qu'avec toute la bonne volonté du
monde de votre part nous avons eu par
exemple l'année dernière la fâcheuse
surprise d'avoir vu que certaines de vos
dispositions ne dépendent pas de vous et
dépendent bien évidemment d'autres
missions d'autres ministères je prends
l'exemple par exemple des des bracelets
d'éloignement qui n'étaient pas financés
par le ministère de la justice où nous
étions nombreux sur en pleine nuit pour
se mobiliser pour essayer de refaire un
fléchage budgétaire sur ce sujet mais
voilà je nous serons vigilants avec vous
sur le fait que certains certaines
dispositions ne dépendent pas de votre
ministère c'est c'est un peu votre
frustration et il faut quand même faire
attention absolument à tout ce genre de
choses
moi j'aurais juste revenir au delà des
violences et je vous remercie pour tout
ce que vous avez tout ce que vous avez
dit plutôt sur les problèmes d'égalité
salariale et aussi de ce qui va
forcément arriver après cette crise
sanitaire qui va être cette crise
économique
j'ai peur que les femmes soient les
premières sacrifiées dans tous domaines
parce que voilà c'est souvent la loi du
genre dans les entreprises et je voulais
savoir où on en était déjà sur l'égalité
salariale de l'inspection du travail
puisque votre prédécesseur disait que on
allait avoir plus inspecteurs du travail
pour aller dans les entreprises vérifier
cette égalité salariale et si dans les
mois à venir
il n'y en aurait pas aussi cette mission
de vérifier que à poste constant on ne
sacrifie pas plus d'hommes que de femmes
dans malheureusement les les plans
sociaux que nous allons sûrement vivre
dans les mois qui viennent et surtout en
début d'année prochaine
voilà merci notre collègue martine
filleul et ensuite je vous laisserai
répondre à ces deux premières questions
madame la ministre
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre je voulais à montrent qu'ils
aient vraiment chaleureusement de votre
présence parmi nous nous avons vraiment
un trop plein de questions à vous poser
compte tenu des compte tenu des
circonstances et je limiterai mon propos
a aimé question à 4 la première concerne
votre budget et surtout les moyens
humains mis à la disposition du service
des droits des femmes et de l'égalité
entre les hommes et les femmes puisque
ce service ne compte aujourd'hui que 25
équivalents temps plein c'est peu pour
la situation que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui est très peu pour l'ambition
qui est celle de
du gouvernement et de vous mêmes puisque
nous avons entendu plein de
détermination
par ailleurs est également les
directions régionales et départementales
sont également sous dotées le rapport
boké bazin disait qu'il y avait cent
vingt-quatre tp sur l'ensemble du réseau
alors que le besoin est évalué à 140
sachant que par ailleurs il y à des
postes qui sont pas pourvus à ce jour
donc je voulais savoir si ce sujet vous
importez si vous aviez envie d'y
apporter des réponses et des solutions
car au delà des moyens financiers il
faut aussi pesé dans l'interministériel
et que les droits des femmes se fassent
valoir plus largement par ailleurs
deuxième sujet je voulais vous
interroger sur les places d'hébergement
sur les 1000 qui ont déjà été annoncés
dans mon département le besoin est et
est évalué à 113 places d'hébergement
supplémentaires
au final dix seulement ont été obtenus
dans le pas de calais c'est simplement
20 ans également qui ont été obtenues
alors que ces deux départements
malheureusement se distingue par des
faits de violence tout à fait important
donc c'est ces places d'hébergement on
tarde vraiment à en voir la réalité dans
nos territoires est ce que cette
opérationnalité va maintenant
s'accélérer
enfin je voulais enfin non pas enfin
mais je voulais évoquer également les
familles monoparentales c'est comme vous
je pense un fait structurels dans notre
société nous allons avoir de plus en
plus de familles monoparentales et c'est
un facteur important d'inégalités alors
vous avez évoqué la question des
pensions alimentaires
françois hollande avait
décidé de ce paiement des pensions
alimentaires par la caisse d'allocations
familiales mais votre prédécesseur
madame schiappa avais je crois commander
une grande enquête et une grande étude à
propos des familles monoparentales en
elle devait nous livrer ses conclusions
je crois un an après et malheureusement
nous n'avons pas enfin moi en tout cas
je n'en ai pas eu connaissance
donc je voulais savoir si vous alliez
effectivement vous atteler au chantier
des autres inégalités que celle des
pensions alimentaires
la question des modes de gamme est aussi
j'allais dire de des difficultés liées à
l'emploi des discriminations à l'emploi
pour les chefs de famille monoparentale
enfin un quatrième sujet peut-être un
peu éloigné de nos préoccupations mais
tout de même
moi je m'inquiète beaucoup de la
situation en pologne tout en étant
admiratif de la mobilisation des femmes
pour que l'avortement soit encore
autorisée en pologne
est ce que la france va s'investir pour
la défense de ses droits
je dirais élémentaires en europe voilà
je vous remercie beaucoup de votre
attention je vous laisse madame le
ministre répondre à ces deux premières
de premier jet de questions pour votre
information
une partie de la délégation a envoyé un
courrier au ministre au pardon à
l'ambassadeur de pologne en france sur
le sujet denis vg en pologne
merci à vous merci mais l'amoureux vos
questions je vais commencer
madame la présidente par répondre à
votre question en ce qui concerne
l'utilisation des crédits de 2020 alors
on a 4 millions d'euros supplémentaires
qui ont été octroyés auxquels il faut
ajouter la levée de réserve de
précaution de 1,2 million d'euros
et je peux vous dresser ici les
différents usages qui ont été faits de
ces différents crédits
nous avons utilisé 3 millions d'euros
pour soutenir les associations locales
et pérenniser les différents dispositifs
d'information et d'accueil
deux femmes victimes de violence dans 40
centres commerciaux
nous avons utilisé 2,2 millions d'euros
dont la levée de réserve dite de
précaution de 1 million d'euros 1,2
million d'euros dont je vous parlais
tout à l'heure pour un la plateforme de
recherche de solutions d'hébergement et
la prise en charge de places
d'hébergement pour les auteurs de
violences de subventionner la permanence
téléphonique relative aux auteurs de
violences conjugales et 3 l'ouverture de
15 premiers centres de prise en charge
développeurs violente de violences
conjugales
bien sûr nous allons suivre de très près
la situation avec olivier derand
également en ce qui concerne les droits
d'accès à la contraception et à l'ivg et
g parce que cette crise sanitaire qui
est liée à l'épidémie ne doit absolument
pas constitué un frein aux droits
fondamentaux des femmes en matière de
santé sexuelle particulièrement ce qui
concerne l'accès à la contraception et
ivg et dans ce cadre d'ailleurs je suis
sûr que vous le souhaitez mais
j'aimerais le rappeler la ligne d'écouté
sexualité contraception et ivg est
maintenu via une plateforme téléphonique
est ouverte de 9 heures à 20 heures en
métropole et le du lundi au vendredi et
de 9 heures à 17 heures aux antilles
pour pouvoir aider les femmes qui en ont
besoin et elles peuvent si elles le
souhaitent également se voir délivrer la
pilule ont sapé donc contraceptive sur
une simple demande de leur avec leurs
anciennes ordonnance et puis l'ensemble
des consultations nécessaires aux ivg
médicamenteuses pourront être réalisées
sous forme de téléconsultation si les
femmes le souhaitent et le pradet que le
praticien l'estimera nécessaire
il y a trois simples choses à faire une
la téléconsultation d'information et de
remise des ordonnances de la
consultation de prise de médicaments
qu'ils arrêtent la grossesse et enfin
une télé consultation de contrôle entre
14 et 21 jours pour s'assurer que la
la femme est en bonne santé et puis nous
avons également l'extension du délai de
réalisation des ivg médicamenteuses hors
milieu hospitalier en ville de sept à
neuf semaines d'aménorrhée alors le
gouvernement encourage bien sûr
l'ensemble des médecins de ville et les
sages-femmes libérales à s'engager dans
le maintien des ivg médicamenteuses et
nous avons demandé aux établissements de
santé d'assurer la continuité des ivg
instrumentale et sur votre remarque
même la présidente en ce qui concerne
l'accès aux taxis pardon et oui je peux
dire à hubert pour accompagner les fans
qui ont besoin de fuir leur domicile
je sais qu'il est difficile dans
certaines sur certains de notre
territoire
mais sachez que nous avons financé lors
des derniers confinement plusieurs
trajets de taxi et que évidemment nous
allons reconduire cette opération
pendant cette deuxième partie du
confinement en ce qui concerne votre
question madame la sénatrice darcos vous
m'avez parlé de du plan de de la manière
dont nous allons considérer les femmes
dans le plan de relance et de la manière
dont nous allons veiller au traitement
égalitaire entre les femmes et les
hommes
alors ce plan de 2,2 d'investissement de
100 milliards d'euros représente un
effort tout à fait massif et sous
l'objectif c'est de protéger notre
économie et de préparer l'avenir et
protéger notre économie pour moi s'est
embarquée toutes les françaises et tous
les français dans ce plan de relance et
les femmes dans seront évidemment pas
exclue et il va de soi que l'engagement
financier sans précédent que la france
et l'europe mettent en oeuvre impose une
responsabilité accrue des entreprises et
c'est un point très important et qui
pour ceux et celles d'entre vous qui
connaissent mon parcours est
excessivement au coeur de mes réflexions
et le gouvernement sera très vigilant à
la mise en oeuvre de ce plan avec 1
un suivi des actions et des projets sur
l'ensemble du territoire
nous sommes évidemment attaché à ce que
l'emploi l'inclusion et l'égalité entre
les femmes et les hommes soient
totalement partie prenante de
l'exécution de ce plan est d'ailleurs à
ce titre le groupe l'as raismes à
l'assemblée nationale a déposé et fait
adopter un amendement visant à soumettre
à des contreparties notamment en matière
d'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
toutes les entreprises qui bénéficieront
de ce plan de relance dont la
publication des sous-indicateurs de
l'index de l'égalité professionnelle
pour toutes les entreprises de plus de
50 salariés pendant toute la durée du
plan est également l'obligation de
publier des objectifs de rattrapage et
des actions correctrices pour les
entreprises dont les résultats seront
inférieurs aux objectifs qui ont été
définies par décret j'ai sur la question
concernant nos services il y à madame la
sénatrice effectivement des postes
vacants au sein de ce service était et
c'est un sujet beaucoup plus globale
d'attractivité de l'administration en
administration centrale ou encore sur
les territoires et je vais suivre cela
de très près en lien avec les services
car nous devons avoir le bon maillage
territorial et les moyens d'exécuter
notre politique et avoir les bonnes
personnes au bon endroit sur un sujet
aussi essentiel que celui là est très
important et c'est l'une des premières
questions que j'ai prise avec mon équipe
à mon arrivée et nous continuons d'y
travailler et merci d'avoir un soulevé
cette question en ce qui concerne les
solutions de logement et d'hébergement
c'est évidemment une mesure où nous
avons des dispositifs très importante
sur ce sujet et je peux vous dire que à
ce jour plus de 60 % des places
d'hébergement qu'ils ont été promises en
2020 c'est un ado en 2000 en 2020 pardon
ont été ouvertes
la crise sanitaire à un coup franc
anti l'ouverture de ces places mais nous
sommes tout à fait optimiste quant au
fait que d'ici la fin de cette année
lenny places promises seront toutes
ouvertes alors ces plats sont des
composés de deux manières il ya 370
hébergement d'urgence et 630 en
allocation de logement temporaire et
l'ouverture du calendrier
pardon le l'ouverture du calendrier des
places depuis le 24 septembre 2020 je
pense que c'est intéressant de le
partager
nous avons ouvert 627 place à fin
septembre nous en ouvrirons 721 à la fin
octobre
51 places vont être ouvertes ce qui nous
mènera à 772 place au mois de novembre
et nous ouvrirons 228 places au mois de
décembre pour totaliser les 1000 places
que nous avons promise et pour répondre
à ce que j'ai pu entendre ici et là nous
sommes en mesure aujourd'hui de savoir
exactement où ces places d'hébergement
sont couvertes
parce que ce sont les prospectus les
préfectures pardon qui ont été chargés
de la sélection des projets et toutes
ces places parce que là aussi ça a été
une question qui m'est revenue souvent
toutes ces places sont dans des
structures non mixtes lors de mon
dernier déplacement à avec le premier
ministre jean castex à saint denis
nous avons poussé ni une nouvelle place
pour l'année 2000 21 et ceux qui nous
portera en nombre de places disponibles
pour héberger les femmes victimes de
violence à 7700 d'hébergement d'ici la
fin de l'année 2021
j'ai également parfaitement entendu
madame la sénatrice votre question sur
la pologne et c'est une question qui me
préoccupe beaucoup parce que nous sommes
confrontés de plus en plus et pas
seulement en france ou en europe mais de
par le monde à une montée des
conservatismes qui met en cause les
droits des femmes au sein même
de l'union européenne vous l'avez
souligné au travers de de ce que fait
aujourd'hui la pologne et des droits que
nous avons acquis de haute lutte sont
aujourd'hui menacés et nous devons
absolument lever élever la voix et faire
en sorte que ces droits soient protégés
j'aime cette citation de simone de
beauvoir qui dit qu il suffira d'une
crise politique économique ou religieuse
pour que toutes ces luttes menées de
manière intense soit remise en question
et je crois que c'est malheureusement ce
à quoi nous sommes confrontés
aujourd'hui c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que
clément bonne et moi restons extrêmement
vigilants sur cette question c'est pour
ça que j'ai parlé cette semaine a mal à
la ministre en charge de l'égalité entre
les femmes et les hommes en allemagne
j'ai également parlé à madame helena
d'alice sur ce sujet et nous restons
tout à fait mobiliser nous sommes en
train de réfléchir aux différentes
actions que nous pouvons mener et nous
voulons porter la parole de la france
évidemment sur notre territoire mais
également dans toute l'union européenne
et dans toutes les institutions
internationales pour rappeler que ce
droit des femmes à disposer de leur
corps est un droit tout à fait
fondamental et nous devons lutter contre
ces tendances dangereuses qui sont à
l'oeuvre partout dans le monde
on a vu aux états unis on l'a vu en
amérique latine il faut que nous
protégions le droit des femmes à
disposer de leur corps et
particulièrement leur accès ali vg vous
m'avez également madame la sénatrice
interrogé sur la situation des familles
monoparentales qui sont comme je l' ai
dit tout à l'heure majoritairement
composée de femmes et cette situation ne
préoccupe beaucoup
alors je vais mentionné plusieurs choses
d'abord la mesure des pensions
alimentaires
qui constitue je l' ai dit tout à
l'heure un progrès important et qui va
appeler une amélioration conséquente
pour les femmes et les enfants qui
subissent les mauvais payeurs que sont
certains pères ensuite il y à la
question des études que vous mentionniez
qui sont effectivement encore en cours
et dont nous attendons encore les
résultats et cela porte à en grande
partie sur les différentes
discrimination dont les femmes sont
encore victimes de notre société parce
que je veux rappeler que les
discriminations de genre sont les
premières discrimination au niveau
mondial et nous travaillerons également
sur les bonnes pratiques à ce que je le
vois bien il y as énormément de
personnes d'associations d'élus qui ont
de très très belles pratiques qui sont
mises en exécution sur l'ensemble du
territoire et il serait bon que nous que
nous ayons ce guide de bonnes pratiques
et que nous puissions le partage est
partout nous devons également nous
pencher davantage sur la question de la
précarité au delà des ddd des paiements
de pension alimentaire je pense comme
vous que nous pourrons aller encore plus
loin et c'est un travail que que nous
initions et vous le savez mon
portefeuille inclut l'égalité des
chances dans tous ses aspects y compris
l'aspect de l'emploi de l'autonomisation
économique des femmes
moi je suis convaincu que plus les
femmes seront considérés pour leur
contribution économique politique et
social dans nos sociétés plus elles
sortiront de ces inégalités de ces
injustices sociales et je serais ravi si
vous le souhaitez madame la sénatrice
que nous y travaillons ensemble
merci madame la ministre alors comme il
ya énormément de demandes de questions
je vais les regrouper par trois en
deuxième étape
donc je vais passer la parole d'abord à
notre collègue laurence cohen
ensuite bruno belin et dominique vais
rien merci madame la présidente merci
madame la ministre pour à la fois votre
propos introductif et puis effectivement
le temps que vous prenez pour répondre
le plus précisément possible
à nos questions moi j'ai trois questions
la première c'est effectivement
concernant le budget vous nous avez dit
est en tout cas je crois que tout le
monde peut s'en réjouir qu'il ya une
augmentation des crédits sur le
programme 137
et vous nous préciser à nouveau comme
d'ailleurs marlène schiappa qu' il ne
faut pas se focaliser seulement sur ce
budget mais qu'il y a également
effectivement un travail transversal
vous savez que les associations
féministes et beaucoup de parlementaires
soutiennent le 1 milliard pour en terme
de budget la cette revendication
vous nous dites que finalement si on
fait le compte on n'y est peut-être pas
loin
ou en tout cas c'est votre votre
objectif mais moi j'aimerais avoir un
peu plus d'éléments parce que il y a
également dans cette danse est visé le
fait qu'il y ait un qui lie à un effort
particulier notamment sur les pays en
voie de développement et votre
prédécesseur opposé un peu les choses
nous ne nous opposons pas mais nous
voudrions en tout cas moi je voudrais
savoir quelle est cette part est à quoi
elle est consacrée et personnellement je
souhaiterais que ce soit quelque chose
de différencier parce que c'est une
action importante mais qui ne doit en
rien limiter les moyens qui sont mis
qu'ils sont mais en france donc ça c'est
ma première question ma deuxième
question c'est lé plus globale moi
j'avoue je suis un petit peu dubitative
ou en tout cas parfois un peu irrité sur
le fait que en tant que parlementaire
quand on est dans l'opposition et que
l'on fait un certain nombre
d'amendements je pense notamment à ce
qui concerne l'égalité professionnelle
en faisant un certain nombre de
propositions
c'est à dire à la fois pouvoir pénaliser
peut-être davantage les entreprises mais
si cette cette voie n'est pas toujours
la meilleure en tout cas mettre des
conditions sur les les subventions qui
sont donnés aux entreprises par rapport
à des critères parmi lesquels le critère
effectivement de l'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes est
systématiquement je dirais que les
différents ministres retoque
ces amendements nous disant que c'est
pas la bonne voie et c
or ça fait des années des années qu'il y
a des lois sur l'égalité professionnelle
et on est en 2020 et il ya toujours pas
d'égalité professionnelle donc un moment
donné c'est pas parce que les
propositions viennent effectivement de
l'opposition qui ne faut pas en tenir
compte et j'aimerais avoir votre
sentiment là-dessus j'ai donné un
exemple il y en a d'autres
est ce que vous comptez effectivement
travailler de manière très fin en tout
cas non partisane avec chacun et chacune
pour faire avancer les droits des femmes
la la la troisième la troisième question
que je voudrais vous poser j'ai bien
entendu ce que vous avez dit sur le 39
19 et sur la nécessité de respecter
effectivement le droit la nécessité de
l'ouverture de marchés publics etc
au printemps mais je suis quand même on
va dire choqué en tout cas parce que
c'est une ligne qui a été ouverte par
une association qui la tient depuis
enfin qui la tient
chi chi l'ha qui la met en oeuvre depuis
depuis 1992 qui a fait preuve vraiment
de son efficacité de sa combes et de ses
compétences de son écoute et les
critères que vous donnez l les
remplissent ce qui lorsqu il en faudrait
c'est effectivement avoir pour être 24
heures sur 24 pour être sept jours sur
sept c'est avoir plus de moyens
donc je sais qu'il y à la loi mais est
ce qu'il n'ya pas quand même par rapport
à l'existence de cette association un
moyen de faire en sorte qu'elle puisse
avoir
donc ce marché parce que ma crainte je
vais je vais là dire c'est que
finalement elle ne l'est pas parce
qu'elles n'ont pas les moyens
obligatoirement dans dans la façon de
2,2 parce qu'il y en a qui sont disons
qu'il y ait des organisations qui sont
très compétentes pour pour paraître très
bien sur le papier et en admettant
qu'elle n'est pas ce marché public
finalement on risque d'avoir deux lignes
différentes et ça sera au détriment au
détriment des femmes donc j'aimerais
avoir votre sentiment
et puis une petite question qui est plus
subsidiaire mais on est beaucoup
interrogé en tant que parlementaire dont
elle n'est pas subsidiaire les femmes
qui sont victimes de violences qui sont
mariées qui vivent maritalement quelle
que soit leur situation et qu'ils
arrivent à échapper à leurs bourreaux
sont parfois contraints oui contraintes
obligés de s'acquitter de dettes que ses
compagnons ont contracté je pense au
niveau notamment des loyers etc
et moi je vais dernièrement là j'ai été
sollicité par plusieurs femmes qui
appellent au secours et j'avoue que je
ne sais pas comment les aider pour que
effectivement elle n'est pas à payer ses
dettes qui sont un dû et qui quand même
avec des jugements qui prouve que le
compagnon était violent et qu' il il a
été condamné pour ça donc qu'est ce
qu'elles peuvent faire pour ne pas
s'acquitter des dettes de ce compagnon
merci beaucoup madame la ministre merci
chers collègues donc la parole à bruno
belin nouveaux collègues depuis 2020 de
la délégation
madame à miss merci de votre écoute et
votre disponibilité pour nous ce matin
moi j'en viens au sujet la violence
c'est une réalité dramatique à laquelle
nous sommes confrontés je pense tous
dans nos responsabilités d'élus locaux
et la situation de la ruralité créer une
vraie fracture de solutions dans ces
situations là il n'y a pas de moyens de
mobilité
il n'ya pas donc il n'ya pas de dubert
ya pas de taxes il n'y a pas de ligne de
bus il ya pas de yens disponibles 2
heures du matin a pas retrouvés
le maire
qui fait office et on n'a pas de
solution de logement alors déjà moi ça
m'a toujours choqué que c'est la victime
qui doivent parfois en pleine nuit être
déplacée et non pas l'auteur des faits
en employant du conditionnel s'il le
faut et on n'a pas de solution de
logement donc il faut un moment donné
qu'on se pose avec les bailleurs sociaux
dont c'est la responsabilité en milieu
rural d'avoir des contingents le terme
est pas sans doute celui qu'il faut mais
on comprend tout ce que ça veut dire
c'est à dire que là où il ya des
réalisation d'opérations de logements
sociaux qu'il y ait partout de la
disponibilité fléché à ces situations là
qui existe partout on va pas le nier
parce que aussi déplacé ces familles là
c'est bien souvent s'y déplacer dépassé
pendant ces femmes-là s'est déplacée des
enfants et donc on les sort du collège
ou de l'école du coin du village et donc
s'il ya encore une pénalité pour eux et
puis l'autre réalité aussi des bailleurs
sociaux
moi je rejoins ma collec est intervenu
en premier les familles monoparentales
c'est une situation qui va s'inscrire
dans le temps
c'est une évidence or aujourd'hui on
voit bien que dans les commissions
d'attribution des logements sociaux
quand on a ce type de situations à
défendre les critères ne permettent pas
l'attribution logements sociaux donc là
où elles devraient où elle voudrait
quitter un logement dans lesquelles sont
exposés pour des questions de violence
établi
il faut absolument qu'on mette les
bailleurs sociaux dans la boucle et avec
des obligations de présence en milieu
rural la réalité c'est 15 millions de
français qui y vivent et donc il va
falloir qu'on mette systématiquement je
pense dans les lois des dispositions
diverses dans les situations de ruralité
voit la première intervention j'aurai
besoin mais ça sera un autre sujet aussi
parce que la situation de l'allongement
de nivee g va faire débat avec certains
de nos collègues j'en suis certain il
faudra qu'on ait des des arguments
débiles comme on dit voilà je suis prêt
à défendre en tant que professionnels de
santé c'est un sujet sur lequel je crois
qu'il faut absolument aussi défendre
mais je peux vous assurer qu'il va
falloir qu'on est un mix des des
arguments avec alain servant de nos
collègues même si on les aime beaucoup
merci chers collègues donc dominique
vais rien pour la 3è intervenantes et
après je vous laisse répondre on aura un
troisième cette question suite la dame
la ministre pour qui sied des de faire
cours dans vos questions puisque sinon
les non non c'était pas destination
bruno de là mais comme il reste quatre
autres intervenants à toi vers dominique
merci madame la présidente madame
ministre merci effectivement d'être
présente
je vais revenir très rapidement sur le
30e 1200 opposants vraiment de questions
purement pratique à qui appartient le 39
d'où la question des deux numéros
possible par est ce que l'objectif n'est
pas de se réapproprier totalement ce
service et c'est pour ça que du coup en
passant par un appel d'offres l'état
récupère une chose alors qu'il n'en
n'était pas à l'origine
ou est ce que c'est réellement via un
code des marchés publics est vrai à une
procédure est là dans ces cas là il est
intéressant de savoir quelle est la
procédure et pas seulement il faut que
deuxième sujet je vois que la prise en
charge des hommes semblent être bien sûr
le budget de votre ministère c'était une
chose qui semblait très compliquée il y
a un an de cela
donc je m'en réjouis si c'est bien le
cas vous confiez
le point d'accueil sur les supermarchés
faut le garder dans les supermarchés
parce que ça fonctionne très bien
pas forcément pour avoir des effets
immédiats mais simplement pour
sensibiliser et après donner les
adresses et ensuite les femmes savent où
aller et se diriger l ont été
sensibilisés donc ça fonctionne vraiment
et dans un milieu rural ça fonctionne
effectivement le réseau des délégués on
l'a déjà dit elles ont vraiment besoin
de moyens
deux points qui n'ont pas été abordés
c'est enfin et surtout une la formation
des forces de l'ordre pour l'accueil des
femmes
est-ce qu'il ya quelque chose qui est
réellement prévu ça se fait dans
certains départements dans le
département de l'yonne je peux vous le
dire il y à des formations justement
pour reconnaître en amont des femmes qui
seraient victimes de violence puisque
c'est pas aussi simple que ça de pouvoir
détecter la chose comment faire et
est-ce que vous travaillez avec vous vos
collègues diplôme moretti et darmanin
pour éviter qu'ils les mains courantes
pour veiller à ce que les procureurs
s'autosaisit systématiquement d' enquête
et que ce soit pas forcément à la femme
de porter plainte et ensuite vous
signaler que il ya souvent et notamment
pour les enfants témoins besoin d'un psy
et les délais d'accès aussi sont
vraiment beaucoup beaucoup trop long
merci voilà je vous laisse répondre
peut-être madame la ministre après nous
aurons cinq autres intervenantes donc
peut-être fait des réponses assez courte
parce que compte tenu de de la volonté
de tous les sénateurs de vous interroger
mais je ne doute pas qu'on aura d'autres
échanges par la suite voilà absolument
merci madame la présidente je vais
essayer de faire court
d'autant que certaines questions
reviennent donc ces jeux je vais je vais
être certaine que tout le monde puisse
s'exprimer
madame la sénatrice cohen je vais
revenir sur le le fameux milliards en
2020 permettez moi de rappeler que le
dpt comme tous les documents budgétaires
dans la présentation des quais des
crédits distingue d'un côté les
autorisations d'engagement qui constitue
la limite supérieure des dépenses qui
peuvent être engagées et de l'eau
côté les crédits de paiement qui sont
les crédits qui sont consommés dans
l'année à venir et c'est donc sa mamma
mia a expliqué encore une fois ce fameux
milliards présentée pour le budget 2010
oui 1,116 milliard d'euros ont été
recensés en autorisations d'engagement
pour l'année 2020
c'est une somme qui s'explique notamment
et le dpt l'indiquent par des montants
exceptionnelles qui ont été liés à nos
engagements internationaux vous l'avez
mentionné tout à l'heure cette somme est
correct je tiens à le souligner
notamment parce que il ya eu une grande
participation de la md et je tiens à
souligner qu' on parle d'autorisations
d'engagement et non pas de crédits de
paiement et que s'ils ont pas
d'autorisations d'engagement nous avons
bien atteint les 1,100 neely a alors
maintenant il faut regarder le montant
des crédits de paiement qui ont été
évalués à 5 157 millions d'euros
je suis d'accord avec vous sur le fait
que nous ne devons pas opposer les
actions nationales et internationales
mais et et jeu et je veux je souhaite
que les choses soient présentés
dorénavant de manière beaucoup plus
claire pour éviter toutes les
interrogations et les doutes qu'il y ait
pu y avoir sur cette question notre
cabinet y travaillent d'arrache-pied et
je crois que dans le dpt 2021
vous pourrez constater des progrès
sensibles
vous m'avez également madame la
sénatrice cohen interrogé sur les
fameuses contreparties dont j'ai parlé
tout à l'heure il y a je pense des
mécanismes qui peuvent nous permettre de
demander de manière tout à fait légitime
aux entreprises dans lesquelles nous
investissons pour relancer notre
économie
eh bien nous pourrons leur demander
effectivement qu'il y ait ces
contreparties et nous pouvons le faire
de manière intelligente moi je crois à
l'intelligence collective
ne perdez pas de vue que les entreprises
ont autant besoin des hommes qu'ils ont
besoins des femmes pour relancer leurs
économies et je pense que l'amendement
qui a été votée va imposer une
transparence renforcée sur les résultats
de l'index pour les entreprises qui
bénéficient en particulier de ces textes
du plan et elisabeth bornes et moi
sommes totalement mobilisés sur ce sujet
nous avons encore fait une communication
cette semaine là dessus nous avons été
plutôt collaborative ces dernières
années sur les communications du plan
sur l'analyse des données qui étaient
présentés sur les différents critères
sur la transparence des présentations
etc
eh bien je pense que l'une des manières
de nous assurer que les femmes soient
correctement traitée dans le cadre de ce
plan de relance c'est de regarder les
les différents sujets sains parra et de
d'en discuter avec les entreprises et de
les pousser à amener des actions
correctives quand elle ne respecte pas
les engagements que que nous attendons
de la part et je suis totalement alignée
là dessus avec vous vous avez également
madame la sénatrice poèmes mentionné le
39 19 et je sens bien
combien cette question intéresse je sens
bien et j'ai croyez bien que j'en ai
discuté à plusieurs reprises avec la
fnsf c'est une obligation juridique
nous n'avons pas d'autre choix je ne
veux pas prendre le risque de faire
quelque chose qui nous met en situation
de contentieux parce que nous n'avons
pas respecté les règles
l'état va financer 100% de cette ligne
l'état est celui qui commande cette
ligne pour les papas que réfléchissons à
la raison pour laquelle nous veulent
nous voulons nous voulons étendre cette
ligne 7 jours sur 7 24 heures sur 24
c'est parce que nous voulons améliorer
le service public et dès lors que nous
demandons à améliorer le service public
et que nous finançons 100% de ce service
nous n'avons pas d'autre choix que de
passer par ce marché public comme je
voulais dit la fnsetr est parfaitement
être informés nous avons
nous sommes convaincus de par
l'expérience qu'ils ont qu'ils ont
parfaitement la légitimité pour répondre
à ce marché et le cahier des charges que
nous construisons nous leur avons
proposé de nous faire des suggestions
d'attention auquel et penserait que
potentiellement nous pourrions d'aidé
sachs sur lesquels ils ville
il pense que nous pourrions apporter
davantage d'attention
je peux vous dire que notre
collaboration avec les associations est
totale les associations ont compris ce
que nous poursuivons mais nous n'avons
pas le choix que de passer par ce marché
public dans l'intérêt de l'objectif que
nous poursuivons de mieux traiter les
les
cette plateforme les femmes au travers
de ses plateformes téléphoniques et je
vous le dis je vous le dirai si vous
posez la question
nous n'avons pas le choix que de passer
par ce marché public
madame la sénatrice vous avez également
mentionné la question de la manière dont
nous collaborons avec le ministère de la
justice
et comment nous pourrons être plus
vigilant sur les solidarités financières
et je vais essayer de faire une réponse
globale mais courte pour donner la
parole ensuite aux autres sénateurs et
sénatrices alors je suis prête à
regarder évidemment là le sujet de la
solidarité financière et je voulais dit
tout à l'heure
nous devons en traiter tous les aspects
et je voudrais souligner qu une mesure
très importante est aujourd'hui en
vigueur et que la première chose que
nous devons nous assurer de faire c'est
de la faire fonctionner avant d'aller
considérer de nouvelles choses à faire
et les moyens financiers que nous
mettons en oeuvre je vous confirme nous
mettons en oeuvre des nouveaux moyens
financiers pour éloigner les agresseurs
en cas d'urgence et tout ça pour nous
permettre de faire face à une situation
qui est totalement inédite quand nous
vous disons que nous cherchons à
éloigner les agressions c'est parce que
nous l'avons vu
les derniers confinement d'abord c'est
une demande des femmes mais c'est aussi
parfois une demande des agresseurs qui
sentent qu'ils peuvent devenir dangereux
mettre en place les mesures qui
permettent de protéger les femmes et les
enfants et faire en sorte que les
agresseurs soient trop être été éloignés
et ses terrains c'est quelque chose qui
nous tient très à coeur et nous allons
également dans le cadre de cette
solidarité que nous devons aux femmes
victimes
nous avons décidé de débloquer l'epargne
salariale pour leur permettre une fois
qu'elles ont quitté le domicile conjugal
de pouvoir trouver un logement digne
dans lequel elles peuvent reconstruire
leur vie et celle de leurs enfants et
aujourd'hui depuis que cette mesure a
été mise en oeuvre
deux cent cinquante mille euros ont pu
être débloqués pour pouvoir aider et
accompagner ces femmes à reconstruire
leur vie et je pense que toutes ces
mesures vont dans la direction madame la
sénatrice de ce que vous souhaitez
réaliser et je serais ravi si vous le
souhaitez que nous puissions en discuter
davantage
madame la sénatrice les miens est ce
qu'il est nécessaire que je revienne sur
la question du 39 19 je les ai déjà
expliqué nous n'avons pas le choix que
de passer par ce marché public et nous
le serons de la meilleure manière qui
soit nous n'avons aucune
par ailleurs aucune volonté d'opposer
l'état aux acteurs associatifs
le 39 19 et une ligne qui a été créée
par la fnsf
nous avons toujours été un partenaire
fort de la fédération
nous les avons toujours accompagné parce
que ce service est important pour lutter
contre les violences faites aux femmes
et il ne s'agit pas de nous approprier
une ligne qui ne nous appartient pas le
sujet n'est pas du tout celui là le
sujet c'est d'améliorer la qualité des
services publics en faveur des femmes
victimes de violences toutefois je
voudrais quand même rappeler que l'état
est toujours légitime à intervenir dans
le domaine de l'intérêt général
et c'est exactement ce que nous faisons
et ce qui nous ressemble
ce qui nous rassemble
donc c'est l'objectif de délivrer le
meilleur service h 24 7 jours sur 7 et
que l'ensemble du territoire y compris
les territoires ultra marins puissent y
avoir accès et que les femmes
malentendantes et les femmes à pratiquer
puisse y avoir accès c'est le simple
objectif que nous poursuivons je crois
monsieur bul
c'est monsieur nains qui est notre
nouveau membre dans la délégation
d'abord je vous souhaite la bienvenue et
je vous remercie d'avoir mentionné la
question de la ruralité la lutte contre
les violences faites aux femmes doit
être un as fait avec la même intensité
où que nous soyons sur le territoire que
ce soit sur les les zones urbaines les
territoires ruraux ou encore les
territoires ultra marins gelés guy mais
je le répète parce que c'est important
nous apportons une très forte attention
à ce que les mesures que nous mettons en
place couvre la totalité du territoire
et en ce qui concerne votre question sur
le logement
nous allons réunir un comité de pilotage
pour expérimenter l'accès au relogement
pour toutes les femmes qui sont victimes
de violences comme je l' ai dit tout à
l'heure sur l'ensemble du territoire
vous avez fait une remarque également
sur les centres commerciaux je crois et
je voudrais juste vous rappeler que nous
avons relancé la mesure avec les alertes
fait au sein des pharmacies 22000
pharmacie là pour le coup il y en a sur
la totalité du territoire
elles font un travail remarquable chez
elle en parlait la semaine 1 est ce que
c'est cette semaine ou la semaine
dernière je ne sais plus mais il me
semble que c'est vendredi dernier j'ai
parlé à l'ordre des facs au président et
à la vice présidente de l'ordre des
pharmaciens et nous avons vérifié les
progrès les différentes mesures qui sont
mises en place pour nous assurer que
dans n'importe quelle pharmacie une
femme qui vient pour demander des
médicaments ou
des voisins ou un membre de famille qui
a connaissance de violence dont une
femme est victime peut le relier au sein
d'une pharmacie qui se connecte avec les
forces de l'ordre et qui peut intervenir
et je crois beaucoup à cette mesure
parce que c'est ce qui va permettre un
maillage territorial qui soit le plus
complet et c'est ce qui frappe les
femmes se sentiront toujours accompagné
en sécurité je veux qu'elles sachent
qu'elles ne sont pas seules dans ces
différents défis auxquels elles sont
confrontées
madame la sénatrice vais rien vous avez
également posé une question au sujet de
la formation des personnels de police
c'est une question extrêmement
importante parce que la reconstruction
des femmes victimes de violence dépend
de la manière dont leurs plaintes sont
prises en considération et de la manière
dont nous les accompagnons dès les
premiers jours lorsqu'elle rentre dans
ce processus de sortie de violence et
avoir un personnel dans les forces de
l'ordre que ce soit la police ou les
gendarmes qu'ils soient parfaitement
formés c'est un sujet très important
pour faciliter ces différentes démarches
et je dirais même qu'il est totalement
indispensable alors si je peux vous
rassurer
les préfectures ont été totalement
mobilisés pendant la période du
confinement et elles vont être à nouveau
sollicités pour dresser un suivi des cas
de violence qui leur semblent remonter
et le cas échéant d'accompagner les
démarches qui ont pu être ralentie
pendant cette période de confinement à
la fin du mois de septembre 55 postes
ont été recrutés c'est à dire 8 de plus
que début septembre et une dizaine
d'autres postes vont être pourvus ces
postes sont là pour faire en sorte que
les préfectures soient toujours plus
réactive et ils seront financés avec des
fonds interministériel pour la
prévention de la délinquance puisque
vous ne posiez la question
et puis il y a également une importance
forte
à donner sur les territoires ultra
marins gelés souligné tout à l'heure
s'ils pensent que vont être créées dont
les nouvelles sur la nouvelle calédonie
la réunion et la guyane et 11 autres
postes sont en attente pour la fin 2020
ou 2021 et ils seront basés en nouvelle
calédonie en polynésie française à manic
sur la réunion et la guyane où vous le
savez les violences faites aux ânes sont
extrêmement importantes
nous devons évidemment maintenir un
effort constant sur la formation des
personnels des forces de l'ordre le
ministère de l'intérieur a mis en place
les outils nécessaires via la circulaire
du 20 janvier 2020 que ce soit dans la
formation initiale que ce soit par des
modules de elearning ou par des stages
l'essentiel pour nous c'est que toutes
les forces de l'ordre soient et les
références aux sûr je veux aussi
mentionné leurs référents sociaux qui
vont être dans les commissariats et dans
les gendarmeries pour faire en sorte que
ces femmes aient un traitement tout à
fait spécifique et qu'elle se sente
encore une fois totalement sécurisée
pour déposer plainte
et tu sais je sais que trop peu d'entre
elles osent encore déposé plainte vous
l'avez souligné madame la sénatrice
certaines disent qu'on leur propose de
2,2 de faire des maths courante plutôt
qu'une plainte
et bien je peux vous dire que à la fois
les forces de l'ordre et les tribunaux
sont sensibilisés et que nous nous
saurons parfaitement soutenu par le
ministre gérald darmanin ainsi que le
garde des sceaux
voilà j'espère que j'ai répondu à vos
questions
merci beaucoup madame la ministre vous
avez répondu je pense à la totalité des
questions d'ores et déjà posée il en
reste quelques-unes donc oui
rafraîchissez vous vous avez la chance
de ne pas porter de masque comme nous
tous sans réunion ce matin
donc on vous en veut terriblement je
vais passer la parole à notre collègue
joëlle garriaud-maylam ensuite victoire
jasmin et el achak et il y aura encore
deux interventions derrière donc merci
de faire court pour que tout le monde
interviennent et je vais devoir vous
quittez madame la ministre donc je vais
rejoindre je dois intervenir en séance
je vais céder la parole
la place à ma collègue vice présidente
laure darcos et je vous remercie
vraiment pour la qualité des réponses
que vous avez pu déjà apporté et pour
votre engagement
on le sent et les sincères et je vous en
remercie je passe là la place lors
d'audiences donc victoire jasmin qui est
en visio joëlle garriaud-maylam el achak
oui alors un show commence joëlle
bourdon
oui oui mesdames la ministre beaucoup de
mes questions ont déjà eu réponse mais
je voudrais moi aussi il faut féliciter
pour votre engagement votre dynamisme la
qualité de vos propos et je voudrais
aussi attirer votre attention sur un
sujet qui a déjà été évoqué par une de
mes collègues mais vraiment vous
demander d'être ferme aussi là dessus
c'est l'engagement international de la
france sur ces questions la france est
le pays des droits de l'homme dont des
femmes ces femmes ont besoin de nous
parce qu'elles sont très isolés vous
savez j'en suis à mon troisième mandat
je suis la plus ancienne de loin de
cette délégation est partout où je vais
dans le monde je me rends compte à quel
point la france est attendu et la france
fait figure de phare un exemple par
exemple j'étais rapporteur en 2011 sur
la loi zimmermann copé sur la place des
femmes dans les conseils
d'administration
et lorsque je l'avais présentés dans des
réunions à l'international je disais
toujours que nous n'étions pas les
premiers que c'était la norvège qui
avait pensé avant nous et la réponse
était toujours à oui mais vous savez la
norvège compte pas vraiment c'est un
petit pays mais vous la france est
tellement important pour nous donc voila
moi j'aimerais vraiment vous puissiez
travailler de manière étroite avec le
ministre des affaires étrangères pour
développer cette exemplarité faire
passer les bonnes pratiques je pense par
exemple au 25 novembre cette journée sur
les violences sexuelles parce que
vraiment les femmes dans le monde ont
besoin ont besoin d'eux voilà c'est tout
merci merci ma charge au n
victoire qui nous écoute tu peux poser
la question allô allô
bon en attendant que victoire puisse se
rebrancher je vais donc passer la parole
à notre jeune collègue et à schalke qui
est également une nouvelle sénatrice
depuis septembre et qui en plus va vous
indiquer qu'elle et elle connaît
parfaitement nos sujets merci madame la
présidente bonjour madame la ministre
alors je vous remercie m entourent pour
les informations que vous nous avez
apporté notamment concernant les actions
mises en place suite au grenelle est
parmi l'une d'entre elles vous avez
indiqué une avancée qui me paraît être
très importante qui est celle en fait de
la possibilité pour les femmes victimes
de violence de pouvoir porter plainte au
sens même des hôpitaux et pour que cette
mesure ce soit efficace et j'ai pu le
mesurer notamment en temps en tant
qu'avocate il ya un élément sur lequel
j'aimerais pouvoir revenir
vous l'avez abordé d'ores et déjà mais
c'est celui de la formation des
professionnels qui recueille les
plaintes alors pourriez vous nous
indiquez ça a été déjà dit tout
tout à l'heure donc les moyens au niveau
des préfectures les moyens effectivement
qui peuvent être consacrés sur cette
question là mais comment s'articulent
justement cette opération avec les
associations d'aidé aux victimes avec
notamment les unités médico légal au
sein des hôpitaux parce que je crois
vraiment nécessaire de simplifier les
démarches pour les femmes victimes de
violence conjugale de pouvoir les
associer au mieux de pouvoir les
accompagner et de faire en sorte
finalement que ce soit le système qui
s'organise autour d'elle et non pas
finalement elles qui doivent aller faire
les différentes démarches notamment les
démarches administratives et on le sait
c'est un moment qui est important que
celui de porter plainte notamment pour
la suite du suivi judiciaire
donc le point peut-être d'attention
c'est effectivement sur la formation
mais également celui sur l'accord
dix nations des différents acteurs je
vous remercie beaucoup pour vos éléments
de réponse merci mâché raisin victoires
que j'ai entraperçu est ce que tu es en
ligne en tentant pas bien toi ah ça y
est ça y avait choisi d'accord merci
beaucoup merci madame la madame la
ministre
merci madame la présidente et bonjour à
tous les collègues
beaucoup de choses ont été dites madame
la ministre je vous félicite vraiment et
je vous remercie pour les réponses que
vous avez déjà donné
mais pour votre enthousiasme et votre
disponibilité c'est très important pour
nous alors ma question c'est aussi
concernant la formation des gens ont
peur de violences
leur formation alors sociation que des
auteurs eux mêmes ils souhaiteraient que
la durée des formations soit beaucoup
plus longue
les formations qui sont faites avec les
procureurs et aussi les moments tendus
enfin ça a coupé un petit peu mais on a
compris le sens
voilà la chose la deuxième chose madame
la ministre vous avez entendu notre
collègue madame valérie létard qui a
parlé de action logement et des
difficultés des deux logements notamment
les logements sociaux mais les logements
et là plusieurs de mes collègues n'ont
pas les noms que vous puissiez président
autour de 3 ou que la situation actuelle
ne sera pas seul et vrai plus par votre
gouvernement
bien au contraire il ya les moyens avec
action logement pour améliorer la
qualité de la prison pour la prise en
charge des femmes j'imaginais
victoire en entend plus et je crois
qu'elle ne nous entend pas non
bon écoute et je pense que vous avez
compris le sens de sa question et quand
je vous disais tout à l'heure que
malheureusement et toute la bonne
volonté du monde
beaucoup de choses ne dépendent pas que
de votre de votre ministère c'est vrai
qu'il faut qu'on travaille bien
évidemment l'interministériel on
n'arrête plus victoire là quelqu'un peut
lui dire ses parois de sape que ça ne
sert plus à rien bon si ça vous dérange
pas madame la ministre pour que vous
ayez la possibilité après nous répondre
plus largement
j'ai posé la règle et j'ai demandé à nos
deux dernières collègues de poser leurs
questions
d'abord marie pierre monnier qui est en
présentiel dans la salle monory est
ensuite valérie boyer comme ça ça vous
permettra de pouvoir répondre à
l'ensemble des questions et finir votre
propos pour que vous ne soyez pas en
retard votre prochain rendez vous merci
merci merci madame la ministre alors je
vous prie de m'excuser je vous ai
écoutés que je suis allé poser la
question orale dans l'hémicycle et me
voilà en présentiel donc j'ai quand même
entendu une partie de ce que vous avez
présenté et des échanges mes collègues
mais je vais peut-être être redondantes
et je vous prie de m'excuser j'ai quand
même entendu deux choses que vous avez
souligné mes collègues c'est le besoin
de formation donc je ne reviendrai pas
c'est essentiel
le démo sur la ruralité ça m'a fait
plaisir moi je suis élu de la drôme et
j'ai créé un collet fait nous avons créé
un collectif avec des élus drômoise de
la ruralité et il ya vraiment un gros
besoin j'ai vu que vous y étaient
attachés madame la ministre
peut-être que je vous reçois les citerai
sur ce sujet je vous ai entendu parler
d'accompagnement des hommes violence est
important je ne sais pas si cela
correspond à la maison qui a été créé le
même type de maison qui a été créée
arras ses seize centres comme ça que
vous voulez créer ou bien si c'est un
accompagnement psychologique autres j'ai
des élus drômoise et des femmes pour moi
ce qu'ils aimeraient créer une maison
drôme donc peut-être que je reprendrai
contact avec vous on m'a fait remonter
du terrain qu'ils avaient des problèmes
sur les séances de prévention en milieu
scolaire sur l'éducation à la sexualité
j'en suis inquiète savoir si vous avez
un oeil là-dessus si vous regardez
qu'elles ont bien lieu
si les moyens ils sont bien tout à
l'heure je vous entendu parler de
transport hubert mise en place dans les
villes et qu'est ce qui va se passer
dans la ruralité est ce que l'état ne
pourrait pas aider les communes pour
financer des bons de transport à
destination des femmes victimes qui
souhaitent se rendre aux permanences des
associations spécialisées souvent vous
savez chez nous en rural elles sont loin
et peu nombreuses donc le trajet à un
coot est-ce qu'on pourrait pas aidé
parce que vous l'avez bien dit elle même
problème en rural et en urbain et en
oublient souvent la ruralité
vous avez parlé des places d'hébergement
ça a été vous savez un sujet puisqu'on
avait annoncé mille qu'on sait pas vous
mais j'ai entendu tout à l'heure que
vous avez un peu préciser à quel moment
les allait arriver donc ça c'était pour
le bras s'est excusé moi donc moi
j'avais retenu mais j'aimerais que mon
confirmer s'il l'aide de l'état pour
l'hôtel et de 25 euros par nuit parce
que je trouve que ça ne correspond pas
les réalités
le prix d'une chambre d'hôtel est
beaucoup plus importante voilà à peu
près ce que je voulais dire et la
subvention si ça peut exister pour la
création d'équipés mobiles avec
infirmiers travailleurs sociaux qui
pourraient intervenir ponctuellement sur
le terrain
sur la question des violences faites aux
femmes et vous savez que nous nous
allons en drôme comme je suis pas autant
de départements deux intervenantes
sociales en gendarmerie qui sont des
travailleurs sociaux qui s'enseigne
gendarmerie quand j'étais lui à 6 ans et
n'a vécu depuis un an et demi on est à 2
c'est pas beaucoup pour un grand
territoire
est-ce que c'est des choses qui
pourraient être un petit peu plus
développé merci merci marie pierre
valérie boyer qui nous quittons quand
visio situé là et que tu as ton micro je
peux poser la dernière question et en
tentant oui tout à fait écoutez merci
beaucoup pour cette question et merci
beaucoup madame la ministre de la
qualité le goût de vos interventions et
surtout de la bienveillance que vous
montrez vis d'haïti au parlement je dois
tenir par cette période où certains
collègues nous ont dit d'aller dehors et
où les votes qui l'ont qu'ils ont émis
en tt comment dire bafoués
eh bien ça fait du bien et je pense que
ça augure
aussi peut-être d'une collaboration
fructueuse en tout cas je l'espère
madame la ministre je voulais vous
parler depuis leurs études qui chaque
année le fait que 130 milles fille et
35000 garçon celui des viols et
tentatives de viols en plus des 80 14
mai une femme maj majeur et hommes
majeurs selon l'excellent rapport du
sénat de 2018 il est difficile d'évaluer
le nombre de violences sexuelles subies
par les mineurs et je voudrais savoir
comment estimer à l'échelle nationale la
prévalence et violences sexuelles vécue
par les mineurs peut dénoncer elle reste
aujourd'hui très difficile à quantifier
malgré la gravité des chiffres
l'observatoire national de la
délinquance et des réponses pénales
estime que seule une victime sur dix
portera plainte est aussi une plainte
sur 10 aboutir à une condamnation
il est donc indispensable d'agir car
derrière chaque chiffre il ya des
enfants et derrière chaque chip
il ya des femmes et parfois des hommes
aussi aussi madame la ministre espère
que vous travaillerez davantage dans la
conservation de votre prédécesseur avec
nous sur ces questions et parce que ça a
été soulignée par bon nombre de mes
collègues c'est vrai que la lutte pour
les droits des femmes et la lutte contre
les violences sexuelles
ce n'est pas un sujet partisans aussi je
me permettrai de formulé plusieurs
propositions sur lesquelles voudrais
avoir votre avenir
premièrement comment ce ton pour mettre
enfin un terme à ce qu'on appelle la
correctionnalisation du viol le viol est
un crime qui constitue la plus grave des
violences sexuelles
or il dit que les trousses il fait trop
souvent l'objet de disqualification en
agression sexuelle consécutive
constitutif pardon d'un délit par
ailleurs je crois que nous devons
retenir dans notre droit l'état de
sidération psychique parce qu'il existe
des viols sans violence physique
pour autant nous sommes face à une
violence psychologique nous ne pouvons
accepter
ensuite nous devons faciliter la
répression des viols commis à l'encontre
de mineurs en instaurant une présomption
simple de contraintes sondés sur
l'incapacité de discernement du mineur
ou sur l'existence d'une différence
d'âge significative entre un mineur est
l'auteur aussi je crois que le
gouvernement n'est pas allé assez loin
au grand regret des associations et de
la parlementaire que je suis enfin et je
sais que c'est un sujet sensible mais
nous devons aussi permettre le
prélèvement et la conservation des
tissus cellules embryonnaires ou fait
tôt après une interruption volontaire de
grossesse dans la
à l'intérieur quand ceux ci a lieu
évidemment sur une mineure dans certains
cas les victimes portent plainte des
mois voire des années
même beaucoup beaucoup d'années après
leur agression on sait ce que c'est la
mémoire traumatique les éléments
matériels sont donc à l'heure actuelle
impossible à retrouver est en droit
pénal
c'est pourquoi si nous envisageons une
présomption de non consentement pour les
mineurs de moins de 15 ans nous devons
autoriser les jeunes filles pour les
jeunes filles mineures le prélèvement et
la conservation disque aux cellules
embryonnaires ou fait tôt après me dg
dans la perspective d'une procédure
pénale ultérieure en effet tout mineur
de moins de 15 ans décidant de subir une
ivg sera alors informé de la possibilité
de pré dervite conserver ses tissus
embryonnaires ou fait tôt alors je sais
que cette idée doit aimer vraiment bien
parce que là c'est quasiment tout seul
et aux requins et enfin excuse moi et
enfin j'ai une dernière question vous
avez évoqué tout à l'heure les pensions
alimentaires
j'aimerais bien connaître comment on
responsabilise les mères et pères pardon
compte tenu du fait que désormais ça
passe par la caf
je vous remercie pardon valait rien mais
en effet d'ailleurs c'était des sujets
sont passionnants mais je pense que
madame la ministre pourra revenir sur
justement d'aider des sujets aussi aussi
important que ne sont pas être traitées
en deux minutes de réponse moi je
voulais juste vous préciser donc la
question de notre chère victoire qui est
voilà il des problèmes de connexion donc
et vous vous posez la question cela dure
et la formation des hommes auteurs de
violence sur le logement et la situation
d'action logement qui avait donc été
donc enfin valérie létard avait posé la
question en question d'actualité et donc
elle vous remercie pour fort-de-france
et pour tous les outre mer madame la
ministre je vous laisse la parole et est
donc en effet vous pouvez essayer de
répondre si possible à quelques
questions
sachant que
voudrait invitera bien évidemment
sûrement sur des sujets plus précis et
sur les auditions plus précise je vous
remercie madame la sénatrice et je vous
remercie
je vais je vais essayer d'être succès la
sénatrice garriaud-maylam votre votre
conviction et votre enthousiasme à
défendre notre diplomatie
féministe encore de notre pays est
exactement le même que le mien j'ai eu
la chance de travailler avec différents
pays dans le monde de vivre sur
différents continents et à chaque fois
vous ne pouvez imaginer la fierté que je
ressens de voir combien les valeurs que
nous portons en tant que pays des droits
de l'homme sont reconnus et sont
appréciés de partout donc ma volonté de
faire rayonner ses valeurs qui sont les
nôtres
de par le monde la de limite que le
coronavirus vraiment et c'est
extrêmement frustrant parce que il y a
tellement de choses que nous aurions pu
faire mais que nous ne courrons pas fait
avec nous devons père soit de manière
virtuelle mais peut-être savez vous que
nous nous nous travaillons avec le
mexique ce et avant avec le mexique et
onu femmes parce que je ne veux pas
parler que de ce qui ne va pas la
pologne il ya des choses à régler mais
il ya aussi des choses qui fonctionnent
dans notre diplomatie
le support que nous importons au docteur
mukwege qu'on appelle le docteur qui
avait par les femmes
le travail que nous faisons pour
organiser un grand événement sur
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
avec onu femmes et avec le mexique tout
cela montre la volonté de notre
gouvernement à porter ou et fort nos
valeurs et à dépendre cela en termes de
diplomatie
féministe sachez que nous sommes
totalement engagés
je le suis en tant que ministre mais je
le suis aussi à titre personnel parce
que quand notre pays comme le monde ne
va pas bien comme c'est le cas
aujourd'hui
il faut apporter des valeurs positives
qui sont les valeurs des droits de
l'homme donc nous suivons
évidemment les engagements que nous
avons pris lors du g7 à biarritz et nous
allons tout faire pour être fier de ceux
de cet événement encore une génération
égalité que nous organiserons je
l'espère au mois de juin 2021
merci pour votre question à l'anah
sénatrice madame la sénatrice chaque
vous avez raison de souligner en fait il
y a deux acteurs clé dans le processus
de traitement des violences faites aux
femmes
c'est l'accueil de leurs plaintes
lorsqu'elles vont dans les gendarmeries
ou les commissariats
mais c'est également lorsqu'elles vont à
l'hôpital pour se faire soigner et
parfois elles n'ont pas la volonté de
déposer plainte mais les médecins ont
cette capacité à comprendre à entendre
et à aider et il est donc tout à fait
crucial de faire en sorte que dans l'est
au sein des enceintes hospital est
hospitalière bardon les fans puissent
avoir accès aux services de police et de
gendarmerie et j'ai visité à saint denis
mais également en bretagne sud dans le
morbihan est également à angers
récemment trois centres qui font un
travail absolument remarquable avec des
médecins excessivement engagés et
motivés
j'en ai discuté avec olivier derand et
nous avons l'intention de détendre ce
genre de solution sur l'ensemble du
territoire est l'objectif de cette
mesure
cette personne que les femmes qui sont
hospitalisés soit qu'ils n'osent pas
aller porter plainte soit qu'ils n'ont
pas envie d'aller porter plainte soit
encouragée à le faire par des officiers
de police judiciaire qui viennent au
sein des hôpitaux pour pouvoir les
accompagner
alors à ce jour comme je vous le disais
tout à l'heure nous avons signé trois
conventions
enfin 30 convention et airports avait
répertorié la circulaire du 23 septembre
2020 ainsi que les tribunaux a favorisé
cette démarche dans le cadre de
l'amélioration à l'accueil et à la prise
en charge des victimes qu'on jurerait
conjugale et au 13 octobre 2020 il ya
cinq ans quatre préfectures qui ont
signé la convention intégrant
l'amendement sur la prise de plainte et
l'hôpital dix autres conventions de
retraite de
être signé d'ici la fin de l'année
malheureusement la crise sanitaire n'a
pas aidé parce que nos médecins et nos
infirmières et noack soignants sont
occupés à gérer les problématiques de de
la pandémie mais je peux vous dire que
nous serons très attentifs pour des
plateaux déploiement territorial de
cette mesure notamment je le répète
encore sur les territoires ultramarins
et dans les zones rurales pour que tous
nos toutes les femmes dans l'entièreté
de notre pays soit bien accompagné
madame la sénatrice victoire geste mines
ou jasmin d'euros j'espère que vous nous
entendez jasmin pardonnez moi j'espère
que vous nous entendez bien parce que
c'est vrai que la ligne n'était pas très
bonne mais j'ai compris votre question
et je veux que vous sachiez que très
conscients que nous sommes du fait que
par exemple à la réunion les femmes
reçoivent trois fois plus de
propositions sexuelles lourdement
insistante malgré le refus qui dont
elles peuvent faire par effet de que en
martinique et en guadeloupe
une femme sur cinq est victime de
violence conjugale a évidemment attiré
notre attention je connais bien les
territoires ultramarins parce que j'ai
longtemps travaillé là bas
sachez que le programme 137 bénéficie en
2021 efforts budgétaires conséquents
comme je vous l'aï dit tout à l'heure et
qu' il va nous permettre de faire une
meilleure couverture des
d'accompagnement sur les territoires
ultramarins
nous allons renforcer les aides
financières que nous apportons aux
associations et nous allons étendre
comme je voulais dit tout à l'heure
l'accès à la ligne 39 19 parce que la
cause du décalage horaire
il y avait une fenêtre de tir
relativement court pour les femmes ultra
marines pour accès pour avoir accès à
ces à céline là et je rappelle en outre
qu'en 2020 les territoires ultra marins
vont faire l'objet d'une aide 2021 pardo
2020 le mille
enfin 2020 et 2021 les territoires ultra
marins vont faire l'objet d'une
attention particulière puisque sur les
places des baies
je mens nous allons en avoir 98 qui vont
être créés et je vais être très
attentive notamment l'une de vous l'a
souligné sur le sujet de l'action
logement il ya une partie importante des
postes d'intervenants sociaux qui vont
être créées au sein d'eads et des
commissariats et des gendarmeries
il y en a une partie qui a été créée en
2020 et nous allons continuer cet effort
et ce travail en 2021 et nous avons
décidé de créer trois centres de prise
en charge des hommes victimes d amour
violent et ils seront d'ici la fin de
l'année nous allons avoir en fait trois
villes qui vont bénéficier de ces
supports la réunion et guyane et la
martinique
donc vous vous noterez bien notre
volonté de ne pas oublier les
territoires ultramarins dans cette
bataille
madame la sénatrice marie pierre monnier
vous m'avez posé une question en ce qui
concerne l'éducation à la sexualité
moi je suis intimement convaincu que ce
sujet de l'égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes doit être pris au plus tôt
dès l'école et l'éducation à la
sexualité plus globalement les questions
relatives à l'égalité entre les filles
et les garçons a fait l'objet d'un
renforcement dans le cadre des mesures
prises lors du grenelle des violences
conjugales
nous avons prévu jean michel blanquer a
prévu dans son budget une prise en
charge d'un module de formation initiale
et continue sur l'égalité rendu
obligatoire à destination de tout le
personnel de l'éducation nationale et
puis chaque année il y aura dorénavant
un conseil de vie collégienne et un
conseil de vie lycéenne pour réaliser un
diagnostic annuel sur l'égalité entre
les filles et les garçons au sein des
milieux scolaire et enfin nous allons
lancer prochainement une mission j'ai
signé la lettre
cette semaine nous allons lancer avec
jean michel blanquer
une mission relative à l'évaluation de
l'éducation à la sexualité du cours
préparatoire jusqu'au lycée cette
mission aura notamment pour objectif
d'évaluer l'efficacité d'éducation à la
sexualité est d'identifier les freins ou
au cou les obstacles qui sont rencontrés
dans cette éducation transversale et
fort du constat que nous avons fait la
mission formulera des recommandations 1
pour lever ces freins et et rendre plus
visible l'ensemble des actions relatives
à l'éducation à la sexualité
madame la sénatrice mme odile vous avez
également mentionné les les actions qui
sont menées sur le logement et les
places d'hébergement pour les femmes
en complément de ce que j'ai dit tout à
l'heure je veux insister sur le
caractère tout à fait prioritaire de
cette action parce que il faut que nous
puissions éloigner les femmes victimes
des foyers où leurs agresseurs vivent
je crois que le sénateur a dit tout à
l'heure qu'il ne comprenait pas pourquoi
c'était les femmes qui doivent partir je
veux préciser que nous donnons le choix
aux femmes de rester ou de partir
d'éloigner les hommes quand c'est
nécessaire ou d'éloigner les femmes
quand elles le souhaitent sachez
monsieur le sénateur que certaines
femmes ne veulent pas rester dans le
foyer pour plusieurs raisons parce que
quand elles iront dans la salle de bain
elles se souviendront d'une gifle
parce que quand elles iront dans la
cuisine elles se sont souviendront d'une
insulte donc sachez que nous voulons
leur donner la possibilité de choisir ce
qu'elles veulent et quand elle décide de
partir il faut que nous soyons en mesure
de leur offrir un logement digne pour
qu'elle puisse se reconstruire
nous avons donné une importance
particulière là encore aux territoires
ultramarins madame la sénatrice jasper
et nous avons augmenté parce que j'ai eu
la question mais je ne suis plus très
sûrs d'eux qu'ils me la poser la
question d'aidé de 2 des prix des
nuitées alors nous avons décidé
d'augmenter pour l'ile-de-france et les
pieds dit ouah ultramarins où nous
savons que le prix des logements est
plus élevé nous les avons augmentés à 34
et 35 euros et non richzad ardo nous
réexaminerons comment réhausser le
forfait des 25 euros
parce que évidemment la qualité des
hébergements est importante
je suis évidemment sensible et sur ce
que nous allons construire en 2021 nous
y serons particulièrement attentifs
madame la sénatrice monnier vous avez
évoqué la question des bons de taxi
notamment pour les zones rurales où nous
ne pouvons pas où les femmes n'ont pas
de moyens de se déplacer elles n'ont pas
de moyen de transport elles n'ont pas de
voiture et les premiers bus sont à des
kilomètres
et bien lors du premier confinement nous
avons financé des bons taxi pour que les
femmes en milieu urbain et rural puisse
être mise à l'abri quand elles ne sont
pas véhiculés et c'est un dispositif que
nous reconduisons et qui va totalement
compléter le partenariat qui a été
construit avec le btc hubert madame la
sénatrice valérie boyer je voudrais vous
dire parce que là vous êtes très
précipitée
surtout n'hésitez pas à répondre mme
alain boyer de manière un peu général
mais après si vous voulez répondre plus
précisément par écrit à certaines
certaines questions parce qu'on est
toutes un peu frustré là je vous semble
bousculé nous aussi n'hésitez pas en
tout cas à pouvoir ne répond si possible
par par écrit nous transmettrons à tout
le monde mais vous pouvez lui répond de
manière générale mais c'est vrai que ces
sujets étaient tellement lourd est
important que ne vous sentez pas obligé
de répondre absolument précisément à
tous des cas alors je vais finir par
répondre à madame la sénatrice valérie
boyer est ce que je vous propose
mesdames et messieurs sénatrices et
sénateurs
ce que je vous propose c'est que si les
réponses que je vous ai donné était trop
rapide ou non pas totalement couvert ce
que vous souhaitiez sentez vous libre
s'il vous plaît de nous les envoyer par
écrit et nous prendrons le temps
nécessaire pour vous répondre de manière
qualitative
il est vrai madame la sénatrice bruit
que vous allez fait d'aider des
considérations et des recommandations
qui me paraissent très intéressante
je reconnais beaucoup d'entre elles
ce que j'ai beaucoup échangé avec madame
gaga à thème sur les sujets par exemple
de prélèvement des cellules
embryonnaires et c'est donc j'ai très
très bien compris ce que vous souhaitez
réaliser sachez que la loi et ça je peux
vous le dire maintenant la loi qui
renforce la lutte contre les violences
sexistes et sexuelles a été votée en
et elle a pris des décisions tout à fait
emblématique le harcèlement de rue qui
est maintenant verbaliser grâce à une
abstraction doute rage sexistes passible
d'une contravention de 4e classe et je
veux préciser que la france est le
premier pays en europe à avoir pris
cette décision et nous courons en être
fier le délai de prescription pour les
crimes sexuels commis sur mineurs est
allongée de 20 à 30 ans à compter de la
majorité en vue de laisser davantage de
temps aux victimes pour qu'elles
puissent porter plainte et nous avons
créé une infraction pénale pour tenir
compte des pratiques qui se sont
multipliées 10 ans en particulier le
public féminin comme par exemple les
dénis de voyeurisme l'administration à
l'insu de la victime devait de
substances de nature à altérer son
discernement vous allez par exemple
entendu de la drogue parler de la drogue
du violeur et ce genre de choses et le
contrôle de ses actes qui sont nés grâce
à internet comme le cyber harcèlement ou
le fait de pouvoir mettre des des des
traceurs sur les téléphones des femmes
victimes de violence donc nous sommes
totalement sensibiliser sur ces nouveaux
crimes dont les femmes sont victimes et
nous les suivons de très près sachez que
à ce jour 2005 l'infraction pour outrage
sexistes ont été notifiés par le service
de police et gendarmerie depuis la
promulgation de la loi
les chiffres sont en constante
augmentation parce que en 2020 100 8
infractions avaient été notifiés et en
2019 83 l'allongement du délai est une
véritable victoire également et je veux
le souligner parce qu'elle va permettre
aux victimes de violences sexuelles
d'avoir davantage de temps si elles le
souhaitent pour porter plainte et et
obtenir justice
mais bien entendu c'est un sujet sur
lequel notre engagement et continue et
sur lequel nous sommes évidemment
disposés à travailler davantage avec
nous toutes et tous merci infiniment
vraiment je vous remercie infiniment
pour le temps que vous nous avez accordé
je pense que mes collègues ici présents
et en visio en serons vraiment très
touchés en effet et continuons en tout
cas ce dialogue juste pour terminer vous
avez parlé du projet de sommet de l'onu
prévue en juin 2021 sur forum génération
égalité sachez que nous avons organisé
une grande table ronde de ce pour cet
événement mars 2020 mais la pandémie a
interrompu la dynamique de cette table
ronde mais nous sommes très très très
intéressé de travailler avec vous
pour préparer en effet ce sommet c'est
un sujet qui nous tient vraiment
particulièrement à coeur donc on aura
sûrement l'occasion de pouvoir en
reparler avec vous merci infiniment
madame la ministre
et voilà pour cette audition d'elisabeth
moreno la ministre chargée de l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes qui a
présenté à la délégation des droits des
femmes du sénat
le plan d'action de son ministère vous
allez maintenant suivre l'audition au
sénat du président du conseil
d'administration du groupe suez numéro
deux mondial de la gestion de l'eau et
des déchets cette audition porte sur le
projet de rachat de suez par veolia le
leader mondial du secteur
ce projet de rachat a été lancé à la fin
de l'été dernier mais sans vraiment
l'accord de l'état actionnaire sur ce
dossier le ministre de l'économie bruno
le maire veut des garanties sur l'emploi
je vous laisse écouter cette audition
est vrai que les conditions de ce rachat
peuvent interroger poser un certain
nombre de questions pourquoi ne pas
avoir pris davantage de temps avant
d'examiner l'offre de veolia afin de
permettre à des propositions
alternatives solide d'être présenté
pourquoi ne pas avoir attendu un accord
amiable entre les groupes avant de
procéder à cette cession
quel rôle l'état at il joué au cours de
ce processus
pourquoi avoir outrepassé son vote voilà
une partie des questions que nous nous
posons monsieur le président que nous
posons regard des conséquences
importantes courel rachat de suez par
véolia sur la structuration des marchés
structuration des marchés de l'eau
structuration des marchés des déchets en
france il nous paraît essentiel monsieur
le président que vous puissiez y
répondre mais avant cela je cède la
parole à ma collègue la présidente
sophie primas merci monsieur le
président monsieur le président merci de
venir ce soir en audition devant nos
deux commissions comme l'a justement
indiqué le président longeau la cession
par angie de ses participations dans
suez soulèvent de très très nombreuses
interrogations
la première série d'interrogations
renvoie comme l'a dit le président lugo
aux sessions à aux conditions de cession
des parts de suez par angie entre
l'annnonce de la stratégie de recentrage
du groupe en juillet de cette année la
présentation des offres successives de
veolia en haut puis en septembre et la
cession effective des participations en
octobre quelques semaines seulement se
sont écoulés
ces délais très contraint comme l'a
rappelé le président lugo était
clairement insuffisant pour permettre un
examen complet de l'impact de cette
session en particulier au regard du
droit de la concurrence ainsi peut-être
et surtout au regard d'autres offres le
fonds d'investissement ares dian par
exemple ayant renoncé à déposer une
contre-offre vous pourrez peut-être
l'aborder
si nous sommes interrogatif c'est parce
que nous souhaitons savoir quel est le
devenir du capital détenue par une gigue
en suède et que ce devenir du capital
détenue par angie dans suez est posée 2
depuis l'expiration du pacte
d'actionnaires c'est à dire depuis 2013
pourquoi avoir bouleversé en quatre mois
une situation a changé depuis huit ans
pourquoi avoir agi dans l'urgence pour
ne pas dire dans une forme de
précipitation vous exposant risque que
cette précipitation soit interprété
comme étant en fait le terme d'un
processus engagé et bouclé auparavant en
chambre ainsi on entend parler d'un
quasi accord entre monsieur frérot et
vous même dès le mois de juin
vous nous direz votre version pourquoi
cette session n'at-elle pas fait l'objet
d'une procédure transparente pourquoi ne
pas avoir attendu après le départ
d'isabelle kocher que la nouvelle
directrice générale choisi par votre
conseil d'administration madame mcgregor
qui prendra ses fonctions exécutif au
1er janvier prochain ne prenne le temps
de réaffirmer elle même une stratégie
opérationnelle pour angie et d'engager
cette session si celle ci entrait dans
sa stratégie
madame kocher était venu présenter la
stratégie d' angie devant notre
commission des affaires économiques le 6
juin 2018 on dirait un siècle et nous
avions été plutôt convaincu par sa
vision est satisfait de voir ensuite que
cette stratégie donnait des résultats
en quoi le recentrage la stratégie
décidée après son départ à plait-il
l'urgence de la cession des parts de
suez
la deuxième série de questions
concernent les relations entre angie
elle est après un quart du capital et un
droit à un tiers des droits de vote
l'état demeure le premier actionnaire
dmj l'état avait légitimement fixé
plusieurs conditions à la cession des
participations dans suez son caractère
amical la préservation de l'emploi et le
maintien sous contrôle français de ces
sociétés
seule cette dernière condition
semblerait rempli par l'offre de veolia
mais pourquoi donc
et on passe en outre la demande initiale
de l'état comment est ce possible que
l'état votre premier actionnaire et pu
accepter
avez vous échangé avec l'état sur les
conditions de la vente avant la décision
de votre conseil d'administration par
ailleurs cette session a été adoptée
d'extrême justesse au conseil
d'administration je rappelle à mes
collègues 7 voix pour quatre contre deux
abstentions les administrateurs de
l'état ont été défaits à cette occasion
pour autant la presse a évoqué
l'hypothèse comme me le disait le
président
jours selon laquelle l'état serait
intervenu en faveur de ce vote auprès
d'autres administrateurs
comment de votre point de vue s'est
déroulé le vote nous sommes monsieur le
président un peu perdu la troisième
interrogation a trait à la stratégie de
recentrage poursuivi par une j annoncé
l'été dernier cette stratégie vise à
simplifier le groupe et à clarifier ses
activités pour lui permettre d'investir
davantage dans les énergies
renouvelables et les infrastructures
pour ce faire angie a engagé une revue
stratégique de ses solutions clients qui
représente les deux tiers de son chiffre
d'affaires mais aussi de ses salariés
des activités non stratégiques
nous pourrions dire au regard de
l'actualité non essentielles pour être
in fine et être mise à distance
angie ayant annoncé un programme de
rotation d'actifs de 8 milliards d'euros
d'ici 2022
l'ampleur de ce chantier est telle que
la presse s'inquiète de risque de
scission du groupe certains d'entre nous
sont j'en suis sûr évoqueront sûrement
un démantèlement
dans le même temps angie a engagé une
réflexion pour rééquilibrer ses
activités de réseaux en france et à
l'international et faire évoluer ses
participations dans gdf le distributeur
de gaz et grt gaz de transporter comment
répondre aux inquiétudes suscitées par
l'annoncé de cette stratégie de
recentrage et comment garantir que de
3,4 milliards d'euros dégagée par la
cession de suez soit effectivement
alloués au financement des énergies
renouvelables et des infrastructures
enfin cette session n'est-elle pas le
prélude d'un profond remaniement des
activités d' angie sur le marché du gaz
si les participations de ger des pardons
grdf et grtgaz devaient à leur tour
évolué voilà monsieur le président avant
de vous laisser répondre je vais vous
dire que nous assistons peut-être
aujourd'hui aux contrecoups de la loi
pacte qui avait été d'ailleurs je le
rappelle rejeté par le sénat
le gouvernent gouvernement avait en
effet souhaité dans ce texte à baisser
la part du capital d' angie devant être
conservé par l'état sur ce dossier je
m'interroge sur les changements de pied
de l'état actionnaire de l'état stratège
dont nous avons pourtant besoin comme
l'a souligné le haut commissaire au plan
ce matin même pour accélérer la reprise
et réussir la transition énergétique
voilà monsieur le président que les les
sénateurs voilà beaucoup de questions
donc je vais essayer de je vais essayer
de vous apporter quelques éléments de
réponse et puis bien sûr la session de
questions qui suivra permettra si j'ai
pas été clairs sur tel ou tel aspect ou
si j'ai oublié tel ou tel aspect d'y
revenir alors peut-être juste un mot de
présentation mois ggg une longue
carrière d'industriels essentiellement
dans la chimie j'ai passé quinze ans
comme dirigeant de deux groupes de
chimie successifs rhodia puis solvay le
second ayant acheté le premier et j'ai
décidé la soixantaine venant de changer
un petit peu mon type d'activité en
devenant non exécutif comme on dit dans
nos dans nos métiers c'est à dire des
activités de conseil d'administration et
je suis aujourd'hui administrateurs
d'axa administrateurs d'airbus et puis
depuis deux ans président du conseil
d'administration d' angie sûr être de
2,2 éléments préalable pour bien
comprendre ce qui s'est passé le premier
touchant à l'histoire entre angie et
suez et le second touchant à la
stratégie d' angie telle qu'elle est
exprimée aujourd'hui
alors l'histoire d' angie est au-dessu s
vous l'avez vous l'avez rappelé nous
lorsque
gaz de france et un groupe qui
s'appelait suez mais qui n'est pas le
sujet d'aujourd'hui se sont rapprochés
il y a maintenant 12 ou 13 ans il était
décidé je crois même rappelé que c'était
une initiative de l'état et peut-être
même du président de la république de
l'époque il était décidé que les
activités d'environnement celle qui
s'appelle suez aujourd'hui ne ferait pas
partie de ce grand ensemble mais
deviendra une société autonome dont le
capital serait mise en bourse et angie
gdf suez à l'époque conservait une
participation dans un premier temps dans
le cadre d'un pacte d'actionnaires qui
l'obligeait effectivement à être un
actionnaire stable de cet ensemble pacte
d'actionnaires qui est venu à échéance
en 2013 et donc depuis 2013 suez est une
simple participation financière pour
angie nous détenons détenions 32% du
capital
nous avions et nous avons toujours
d'ailleurs deux administrateurs qui
siègent au conseil de suez mais nous
n'avons aucun lien opérationnel entre
les deux sociétés
nous faisons une dizaine de millions
d'euros d'activité sur des projets
communs ce qui pour des groupes qui font
50 60 milliards de chiffre d'affaires
s'agissant des angie ou une vingtaine de
milliards de chiffre d'affaires
s'agissant de suez représente la taille
d'une tête d'épinglé
donc c'est vraiment deux sociétés qui
sont qui vivent dans des métiers qui ont
quelques éléments quelques points de
contact et peut-être dans certaines de
certains des territoires que vous
représentez vous nous connaissez et
quelquefois ensemble mais pour
l'essentiel nous travaillons de manière
totalement totalement séparées et
effectivement depuis depuis sept ans
depuis la fin de ce pacte d'actionnaires
la question est régulièrement posée à
angie qu'allez vous faire de votre
participation chez suez et lorsque je
suis arrivé comme président du conseil
d'énergie
ma première réaction d'industriels était
de dire 30% nous industriels détenant
une participation de 30% dans un autre
groupe industriel c'est soit trop soit
trop peu soit trop parce qu'en fait on
on constate qu'effectivement nous
n'avons pas de nous n'avons pas
d'activité commune et on n'a aucune
raison de détenir une participation dans
un autre groupe industriel le temps des
noyaux durs est vraiment est vraiment
loin de nous nous avons d'autres
utilisations possibles de de ces
capitaux soit au contraire nous aurions
pu imaginer un rapprochement et une
intégration des deux groupes et je pense
qu'il ya eu beaucoup de débats au sein
de la direction et du conseil
d'administration d' angie autour de ces
sujets nous avons annoncé avec isabelle
kocher en décembre 2018 que nous nous
satisfaisons de notre position
d'actionnaire à 32% et que nous ne
souhaitions pas à court terme la faire
évoluer pourquoi l'avion nous dit parce
qu'on entrait dans la face dans lequel
le conseil d'administration de suez
devait choisir un dirigeant bertrand
camus que vous avez vu hier puis choisir
d'ailleurs dans quelques mois plus tard
un président fait du bas rhin que vous
avez également vu hier et il nous
paraissait important que ces choix se
fasse dans un contexte de relative
stabilité
donc ça c'est l'histoire de nos deux
groupes alors maintenant la stratégie la
stratégie d' angie alors effectivement
cette stratégie a été a fait l'objet de
beaucoup de travaux du conseil
d'administration depuis depuis presque
un an et nous avons conclu et et
vraiment je voudrais revenir sur un de
vos commentaires qui qui pour le coup me
paraît un petit peu mais connaître ce
qu'est la vie des affaires et la
gouvernance aujourd'hui
l'organe qui décide de la stratégie du
groupe
c'est le conseil d'administration et le
directeur général est en charge de
mettre en oeuvre cette stratégie est
effectivement le conseil
d'administration en juillet dernier se
sentait parfaitement légitime pour
approuver de nouvelles orientations
stratégiques pour angie qui ne sont
d'ailleurs pas un virage à 180 degrés
par rapport à la stratégie que nous
menions jusqu alors mais qui traduisent
notre souci de simplifier le groupe et
de le concentrer sur des métiers dans
lesquels nous avons la capacité de
défendre des positions de leader mondial
je ne voulais pas dire l'introduction
j'aurais peut-être dû le rappeler ce
qu'est n'jie finalement est à la fois
bien connue parce que
11 millions de foyers français reçoivent
une facture avec le sigle d angie sûr
sur cette facture mais en réalité nous
sommes un groupe mondial 60 milliards de
chiffre d'affaires je le disais 170
mille personnes présentes dans un
ensemble de métiers les infrastructures
gazières transport de transport et
distribution de gaz essentiellement en
france mais un petit peu à l'étranger
la production d'électricité nous sommes
le premier générateur privés
d'électricité par privé on veut
simplement dire que nous ne sommes pas
un acteur nous sortons de ce classement
les acteurs historiques comme edf ou
enel ou iberdrola
si on exclut ces acteurs-là nous avons
90 gigawatts de capacités installées
mais très peu en france donc nous ne
sommes pas connus d'en passer par cette
activité là en france nous produisons
d'électricité essentiellement au benelux
en particulier en belgique où nous avons
un parc de centrales nucléaires et en
amérique latine
troisième métier les renouvelables je
vais y revenir et puis quatrième métier
nos activités à la fois
d'infrastructures urbaines réseau de
chaleur réseau de froid et activités de
services donc face à cet ensemble un
petit peu complexe le conseil
d'administration a annoncé effectivement
le 30 juillet dernier quelques
simplifications la volonté d'accélérer
nos développement dans les renouvelables
pourquoi parce que le marché des
énergies renouvelables de explose dans
beaucoup de parties du monde
nous sommes un très gros acteurs au plan
mondial au niveau des plus grands que
sont enel iberdrola ou edf et nous avons
la volonté de continuer à croître dans
ces métiers et pour cela nous avons
besoin de moyens financiers
supplémentaires à y affecter
et puis le deuxième métier dans lequel
nous avons choisi de croître ce sont les
infrastructures infrastructures gazières
à l'international mais aussi
infrastructures urbaines nous avons le
sentiment que l'accompagnement des
collectivités en france ou dans les
autres pays où nous opérons autour de
projets de réseaux de chaleur réseau de
froid réseau de charge de véhicules
électriques smart cities dans un certain
nombre de cas tout ceci représente un
potentiel très important de contribuer à
la transition énergétique et le groupe
souhaitait là aussi
disposer des moyens nécessaires pour
accompagner ces efforts
en revanche dans nos activités de
services qui représentent à peu près 20
milliards d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
nous avons décidé de les classer en deux
catégories celles qui sont véritablement
liée aux problématiques énergétiques et
celles ci ont vocation effectivement à
rester à rester dans le groupe c
représentent à peu près le tiers de ces
20 milliards de chiffre d'affaires
et puis une deuxième partie qui sont des
activités plus loin de la problématique
énergétique installations électriques
installations de climatisation facility
management et puis tout un tas de choses
un petit peu plus loin de ses métiers et
là nous avons effectivement engagé une
revue stratégique et qui est en cours
actuellement pour définir ce que
peut-être l'avenir de cet ensemble de
métiers
et puis nous avons annoncé toujours ce
30 juillet que nous nous interrogions
sur nos participations financières dans
quelques sociétés suez faisait partie de
ces de ces sociétés c'est latella la
plus importante de nos participations
financières mais pas la seule et à ce
moment là j'ai eu effectivement cette
phrase qu'on m'a rappelé ensuite en me
demandant qu'est ce qui peut se passer
pour votre participation dans suez j'ai
dit tout est ouvert et nous regarderons
les les offres qui nous serons qui ne
pourraient nous être faites par les uns
ou les autres
donc voilà le l'histoire qui nous a
amené à cette a7 à cette communication à
la fin du mois de juillet alors je
précise s'agissant de suez ce que nous
vous ont peut-être pas dit hier philippe
varin et bertrand camus que lorsque je
les ai rencontrés chacun pour la
première fois dans ses fonctions
bertrand camus en mai 2019 alors qu'il
venait d'être nommé directeur général de
suez avec le soutien d' angie et de ses
représentants au conseil
d'administration
je lui ai dit bertrand tu es dans une
situation dans lequel tu diriges une
société industrielle qui est un
actionnaire qui s'appelle angie qui va
sans doute pas rester dans la situation
où il est et je lui ai même dit très
explicitement avant la fin de son
premier mandat donc avant la fin de
l'avant en 2022
soit on aura décidé de monter au capital
et d'intégrer suez dans angie soit on
aura décidé de sortir et il faut que tu
t'y prépare si c'est la première
hypothèse
la préparation est sans doute et sans
doute pas dans tes mains en revanche si
c'est la seconde il faut que tu sois
prêt à imaginer un mécanisme qui
permette à angie de sortir de cette
participation dans les meilleures
conditions possibles
et lorsque j'ai rencontré philippe varin
en janvier dernier par un candidat à la
présidence du conseil d'administration
de suez
j'ai à peu près les mêmes propos je
connais très bien philippe on se connaît
depuis plus d'une dizaine d'années
je lui ai dit philippe à un moment ou à
un autre pendant ton le cours de son
mandat cette question va être posée de
l'avenir de notre participation là aussi
on peut monter ou on peut descendre et
il faudra qu'on ait un interlocuteur
pour pouvoir discuter de ces sujets
depuis que philippe et président du
conseil donc depuis le mois de mai nous
nous voyons nous ne parlons une fois par
mois et tous les a toutes nos réunions
cette question est venu sur la table et
je l'ait appelé une semaine avant le 30
juillet pour lui indiquer que le conseil
d'administration d' angie travailler sur
de nouvelles orientations stratégiques
effectivement de ses orientations
stratégiques aller résulté notre
expression de notre volonté de sortir du
capital de suez et qu'il fallait qu'il
s'y prépare
j'ai reçu quelques jours après le 30
juillet et je précise d'ailleurs j'ai
oublié de vous le dire mais les
orientations stratégiques que nous avons
et que nous avons présenté le 30 juillet
ont été adoptés à l'unanimité du conseil
donc qui veut dire l'unanimité veut dire
que les représentants de l'état ont
soutenu d'ailleurs bruno le maire a
exprimé à plusieurs reprises au cours du
mois de septembre son soutien aux
orientations stratégiques dmj mais aussi
leurs représentants des salariés nous
avons quatre représentants des salariés
au sein du conseil jean trois
représentants des salariés en tant que
tel et un représentant des salariés
actionnaires et l'ensemble du conseil
s'est exprimé en faveur de ces
orientations
je reviens à ma petite histoire j'ai eu
un appel d'antoine frérot dans les
premiers jours d'août me disant j'ai
entendu votre communication
nous sommes intéressés nous pourrions
avoir des idées sur la manière de de
vous aider à sortir de cette
participation
je lui ai dit dès que vous avez un
projet venait m'en parler et pas de
contact avec antoine frérot enjoint pas
de contact avec antoine frérot en août
en revanche une demande un petit peu
présente à la fin du mois d'août
d'antoine frérot me disant nous
souhaiterions vous rencontrez le 30 août
qui était un dimanche et quentin
quelqu'un vous demande un rendez-vous un
dimanche
ça fait un petit l'edt c'est
généralement qu'il a envie de vous
parler de quelque chose qui se traite
plus facilement quand les bourses sont
fermées que lorsqu'elles sont ouvertes
et donc ça veut dire que il avait sans
doute préparé quelque chose d'important
mais que je connais que je ne
connaissais pas avant que cette réunion
est effectivement eu lieu pas très loin
d'ici le dimanche 30 août au matin
et là j'ai effectivement été un petit
peu surpris de la proposition qui nous
étaient faites pour par deux aspects le
premier c'est que plutôt que de nous
racheter notre participation de 32 %
l'idée d'antoine frérot était de ne
racheter que 29,9 pour cent et il ya
effectivement une une nuance importante
entre les deux c'est crashed et 32%
suppose de passer par un certain nombre
de deux
deux mécanismes enfin rend nécessaire de
faire une offre à l'ensemble des
minoritaires d'une part et ceci entraîne
canton con quand on met ensemble les
droits boursiers les droits de la
concurrence ceci rend nécessaire une
autorisation des autorités de la
concurrence
donc les 29,9 était une idée à mon sens
astucieuse qui permettait effectivement
de proposer à angie de lui racheter
l'essentiel de son bloc sans avoir aucun
risque d'exécution c'est à dire en étant
certain que l'opération puisse
l'opération puisse se faire et la
deuxième chose qui m'a surpris c'est
elle
l'extrême importance donnée au délai de
dix ans cette offre est ouverte pour un
mois et il faut que nous puissions
avancer au cours de ce au cours de ce
mois là et puis ensuite les choses ont
été largement largement public puisque
antoine frérot a souhaité rendre
publique cette offre qui était pas non
plus absolument nécessaire moi je je lui
avais dit que je préférerais qu'on ait
une série de discussions et des échanges
discrets avant que cette offre ne soit
rendue publique
antoine frérot a considéré que le le
caractère très comment dire l'intérêt
qu'un sujet comme celui-ci allait
susciter rendait difficile de garder la
confidentialité et qu'il fallait donc
rendre l'opération où l'offre publique
ce qui est une très bonne chose quand on
est attaché à la transparence ceci dit
dès lors que vous négociez publiquement
vous négociez sous une avec un certain
niveau de pression ou de oud attention
donc dans la période qui s'est ouverte à
partir du 30 août qu'est ce qu'on a
essayé de faire deux choses côté veolia
nous avons indiqué que l'offre ne nous
paraissait pas en l'état acceptable elle
a d'ailleurs été formellement refusé par
le conseil d'administration de benjy
autour du 10 septembre considéré à la
fois que le prix n'était pas le bon
s'était tue le fret est faite à 15 euros
en considérant que les garanties en
matière d'emploi n'étaient pas
suffisantes et en considérant qu'il
fallait un engagement de veolia que ce
projet puisse se faire de manière
amicale
et puis vis-à-vis de suez qu'est ce que
nous avons fait nous leur avons dit deux
choses
nous leur avons dit nous avons cette
offre sur la table
nous sommes désireux de voir une seconde
offre se constitue et je dis bien nous
sommes désireux nous sommes désireux
parce que quand vous voulez vendre
quelque chose il vaut mieux avoir en
face de vous deux acheteurs qu'un seul 1
et 2 il nous semble nécessaire que vous
engagiez le dialogue avec véolia pour
comprendre ce qu'elle est le contenu de
leurs offres et comment celle-ci
peut-être peu comment celle-ci peut-être
évaluer et améliorer
malheureusement pendant ce mois il s'est
pas produit grand chose sur ces deux
aspects vous l'avez entendu hier un
philippe et bertrand ont refusé tout
dialogue avec avec veolia avec beaucoup
de force et de et de conviction d'une
part et par ailleurs suez n'a pas été en
mesure de proposer une offre alternative
et c'est vraiment dommage parce que je
les dis à nouveau à plusieurs reprises
pages et des citations de presse qui me
rappelle que deux ou trois fois par
semaine pendant cette période j'ai
rappelé combien il était important que
cette offre alternative viennent la
seule chose que nous avons reçue c'est
le 30 septembre donc le jour où se
tenait le jour où expirait l'offre de
veolia un document que j'ose à peine
appeler une offre c'était plutôt une une
expression d'intérêt et misent pas rare
d'y ans mais ne contenant ni prix ni
aucune aucune description du projet
qu'elle qu'elle soutenait qui était un
projet présent rupture 1 puisque l'idée
d'art dian était de faire une opération
consistant à retirer complètement suez
de la cote et d'en faire une entreprise
privée dans le cadre de ce qu'on appelle
un fonds de private equity donc c'était
pas c'est pas le genre de projet qui se
s'est pas un projet anodin et nous
n'avons dans l'offre reçue le 30
septembre pour la petite histoire
d'ailleurs offre reçue une heure après
le début du conseil d'administration
nous n'avions aucun élément permettant
de juger de sept jurés de cette offre
donc nous nous sommes retrouvés
effectivement de notre point de vue il
n'y avait pas d'urgence ou nécessité de
de conclure à telle ou telle date un
angie a plein de liquidités n'a pas
besoin de ces 3 milliard 4 pour faire
ses fins de mois
même dans une année un peu compliqué
comme celle ci en revanche ce qui crée l
urgence et le fait que veolia nous
disent je vais retirer mon offre le 30
septembre si elle n'est pas là si vous
n'avez pas si vous l'avez pas accepter
et à ce moment là et bien soit on
lancera une offre et angie sera pris
dans l'offre publique lancée avec un
inconvénient c'est qu'une offre publique
dans un contexte comme celui ci c'est
probablement 12 18 ou 24 mois de délai
et où on renoncera complètement à ce
projet et le cours de bourse de le cours
de bourse de suez qui était monté de 12
à 16 ou 17 euros allaient probablement
redescendre dans sa valeur précédente et
il ya un risque de perte de valeur
manifeste pour angie est donc ces
éléments là que le conseil
d'administration a balancé après avoir à
la demande des pouvoirs publics obtenu
un délai supplémentaire d'une semaine ou
pas tout à fait de cinq jours en fait
entre le 30 septembre et le 5 octobre et
nous nous sommes retrouvés le 5 octobre
à nouveau en conseil d'administration
avec une offre de veolia qui avaient été
améliorés en terme de prix 18 euros
des engagements en termes d'emploi qui
nous paraissent réelles nous les avons
examinés avec attention et nous les
avons d'ailleurs nos administrateurs
salariés ont demandé à avoir accès à ses
engagements et se sont déclarés
satisfaits de ce qu'il satisfait de ce
qu'il contenait
et sur la sur l'ami qualité veolia
s'engage effectivement à 9,1 d'offre
approuvé par le conseil d'administration
de suez et et
donc nous avions le sentiment du point
de vue de du conseil d'administration d'
angie ou en tout cas de ses
administrateurs indépendants que nous
avions une offre qui répondait bien aux
conditions que nous avions posé alors la
vision de l'état elle était légèrement
différente puisque bruno le maire
souhaitait mais tout comme moi que cette
offre soit amical enfin personne
personne de sérieux ne n'éprouve
beaucoup de plaisir à voir deux grands
groupes français se lancer dé se lancer
des propos très agressif par presse
interposée donc et puis in fine et enfin
moi je vous ai dit tout à l'heure que
j'avais été dirigeant de rhodia qui a
fait l'objet d'une offre par solvay qui
était pas non plus une offre sollicités
sauf que on s'est mis rapidement autour
de la table on a dialogué et on a trouvé
un terrain d'entente et les voies et
moyens pour réaliser une fusion qui je
crois c'est s'est bien passé je suis
bien convaincu qu'une fusion se réalise
d'autant mieux qu'elle est entre
guillemets amical ceci dit pour qu'elles
soient amicales il faut que les deux
parties puissent puisse engager le
dialogue donc pour revenir à mon
commentaire sur la différence de
position entre la mienne et celle de
bruno le maire c'est bruno le maire
souhaitait que l'ami qualité précède la
cession du bloc
benji et moi je considérais que les
choses étant ce qu'elles étaient il
était impossible d'obtenir un accord
entre les deux parties dans un délai
court avant que la cession de ce blog
puisse puisse avoir lieu
donc voilà comment s'est déroulée cette
affaire le dernier point sur sur le vote
là aussi il n'y a pas deux il n'y a pas
de grand mystère sur qui a voté quoi
alors sa page et pas vocation à rendre
public les votes au conseil
d'administration d' angie mais comme il
y eut beaucoup de commentaires sur qu'au
mieux beaucoup de commentaires sur le
sujet je je peux rappeler quelques fait
alors d'abord l'état
dispose de trois sièges au conseil
d'administration d' angie qui est
actuellement composé de treize
administrateurs habituellement 14 mais
comme nous n'avions pas de directeur
général en place et que le directeur
général et administrateur nous avons
treize administrateurs
donc l'état l'influencent de l'état au
sein du conseil et les proportionnelle
au nombre d'administrateurs dont il
dispose il n'y a pas de mystère et je
suis président du conseil je dois
défendre l'intérêt de tous les
actionnaires
donc j'ai un intérêt tout particulier
pour mon premier actionnaire l'état à 20
22 ou 23 % mais j'ai 60 77 %
d'actionnaires qui sont pas l'état qui
compte tout autant sur moi pour défendre
leurs intérêts alors je considère que
mon rôle c'est de trouver un bon
alignement et sur l'essentiel des sujets
nous trouvons un bon alignement entre
les les deux groupes d'actionnaires
l'état et les autres sur ce sujet là mes
autres actionnaires me disait avec
beaucoup de force
18 euros par action
c'est une valeur que vous ne retrouverez
pas avant longtemps
le groupe a des besoins
d'investissements les montants que vous
pouvez dégager dans cette session ils
sont très utiles pour accélérer nos
efforts dans le accélérer nos efforts
dans le domaine des des énergies
renouvelables allez-y et effectivement
on s'est retrouvé dans une situation qui
est finalement assez rare dans lequel
l'intérêt social d'énergie pouvait être
différent de l'intérêt de l'état qui
cherche à avoir et c'est son rôle
une vision de l'intérêt de l'intérêt
public et donc nous avons constaté avant
le début de ce conseil avec bruno le
maire qu'on allait sans doute arriver à
une situation dans lequel l'état et ses
représentants allaient prendre une
position
et puis et puis là le poids respectif
des forces en présence à les conduire à
ce que
à ce qu'une décision différente de celle
que l'état proposait soit prise in fine
et est donc effectivement les
administrateurs indépendants qui sont au
nombre de six ont voté en faveur de l'as
de la session l'état qui avait trois
représentants deux d'entre eux ont voté
contre le troisième s'est abstenu et
puis et ceci est parlant et puis dans
les représentants des salariés un seul a
pris part au vote et à voter lui aussi
en faveur de la cession dont il a eu
cette voix en faveur de la cession et
deux voix contre
donc j'ai pas si c'est une petite
majorité dans nos conseils les
abstentions compte comme des voix contre
en fait il faut avoir une majorité des
des suffrages exprimés donc très
administrateurs il fallait cette voix
pour il fallait cette voix pour
l'emporter c'est bien ce qui c'est c'est
bien ce gars oui pardon oui pardon 13
administrateurs mais onze seulement ont
pris part au vote
donc il fallait six voix pour 6 voix
pour emporter cette décision on en a eu
sept fonctionnement normal du conseil et
et pas grand-chose à de mon point de vue
en tout cas à dire sur ce point bon
voila moi j'ai essayé de vous faire un
panoramique assez complet de sujets qui
sont à la fois complexes mais finalement
assez simple dans leur logique
moi je terminerais simplement pour vous
en vous disant c'était une des questions
que vous me posiez madame la présidente
qu'est ce qu'on va faire de cet argent
alors la réponse et les simples claires
et précises
on a annoncé qu'on on a annoncé qu' on
dépenserait 8 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires au delà de notre
programme d'investissement normal pour
accélérer nos développements dans le
domaine des renouvelables et dans celui
des infrastructures en particulier des
infrastructures urbaines et ben c'est
bien ce que nous allons faire et le
groupe est un très gros investisseurs
chaque année c'est chaque année ces six
à sept milliards d'euros que nous
investissons dans nos différents projets
de par le monde et ben nous allons
pendant deux ou trois ans accélérée est
passé à un niveau d'investissement qui
va nous permettre d'être un acteur
encore plus important dans la transition
énergétique et climatique
voilà ce que je pourrais vous dire dans
cette intervention liminaire et bien sûr
tout prêt à répondre à vos questions ou
à compléter si j'ai oublié tel ou tel
point
merci monsieur le président type de la
commission d'aménagement du territoire
je vais donner la parole aux deux
rapporteurs et madame eb l'hérault
nadine et après monsieur hervé gillé
merci merci excusons oui merci beaucoup
monsieur le président on a vous remercie
de votre intervention nous avons
représenté vous votre votre historique
donc si je comprends bien ce qu'on avait
pu lire juste vous répondez à certaines
des questions qui serait posée mais on
avait pu lire dans la presse que vous
aviez un besoin et c'est urgent de
liquidités et donc vous avez répondu
qu'en fait vous n'aviez pas eu ce besoin
et d'autre part vous avez aussi répondu
on avait pu cru lire et entendre que
tous avaient été assez précipité mais
vous nous avez rappelé les faits et et
le besoin de temps supplémentaire les
raisons pour lesquelles ça n'a pas eu je
voulais parler en fait plutôt des
garanties vous avez évoqué à cette
occasion de ce rachat de cette vente de
des garanties concernant l'emploi vous
avez évoqué cela tout à l'heure donc
est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire un
petit peu plus sur le recentrage donc
des activités de de votre de angie et
nous parler des conséquences qu'il
pourrait y avoir en termes d'emplois
dans cette dans ce rachat et
deuxièmement toujours dans cette idée de
recentrage et bien compris que donc vous
aviez votre développement à venir sur
les énergies renouvelables également sur
tout ce qui concerne des activités et je
voudrais surtout que vous puissiez nous
redire nous dire ce que vous entendez
faire du côté du gaz
bien sûr puisque est-ce que angie entend
réduire ou céder ses participations
distributeurs et transporteurs de gaz
si c'est le cas quelle sont évidemment
les partenaires extérieurs qui pourrait
être pressenti au capital et quelles
sont les garanties kenjy envisage de
prendre pour évidemment toujours qui
rejoint un peu la première question
préserver les intérêts de la france dans
le secteur de l'énergie
je remercie monsieur gillet et puis
merci monsieur le président madame la
présidente
le président du conseil d'administration
merci donc de votre présence vous l'avez
évoqué le contexte de la crise sanitaire
mais je souhaiterais justement qu'on
puisse approfondir ce sujet parce qu'il
interroge aujourd'hui car ce contexte de
la crise du coc vide est il vraiment
propice à une cession des participations
dans suez dans la mesure où ce contexte
des primes l'activité économique et donc
le montant de l'action de la société
un prix supérieur à 18 euros par action
n'aurait-il pas pu être obtenue
l'action de suez ayant pu s'établir à
des montants supérieurs par le passé
donc on s'interroge aujourd'hui sur ses
décisions prises dans le contexte
effectivement actuelle et puis
l'incidence de la crise du coc vide de
19 et plus spécifiquement de la chute de
la demande et donc des prix de l'énergie
sur l'activité le résultat les
investissements d'énergie il ya
forcément une influence donc salée
pouvez-nous nous éclairer effectivement
sur ce sujet là et puis les objectifs et
les modalités de financement de la
stratégie de recentrage du groupe sont
ils adaptés justement à ce nouveau
contexte qui est quand même relativement
contraignant donc merci pour vos
éclairages sur ces sujets pour la
commission des affaires économiques de
me donner la parole à florence blatrix
compta et ensuite à alain cadec mer
madame la présidente monsieur le
président lugo et monsieur le président
du conseil d'administration
donc deux questions le fonds
d'investissement ares dian donc indiqué
ne pas à la presse ne pas avoir eu assez
de temps pour constituer proposer une
offre alternative
et pourquoi donc pourquoi ne pas avoir
donné davantage de temps à cette
solution vous avez une lettre
d'intention que vous dites assez
sommaire mais davantage de temps aurait
sans doute permis de construire un
dossier plus solide et par ailleurs nous
avons appris que veolia pour des raisons
de respect de droit de la concurrence
serait obligé de céder sa part au au
fond meridia mais pourquoi finalement ne
pas avoir recherché aussi une solution
avec le fond meridiam pour la
constitution d'une offre de reprise
autres autre question donc j'ai bien
compris qu'ils avaient quand même
finalement une certes une logique de
recentrage mais également une logique
financière avec une un accroissement
assez substantielle de la capitalisation
boursière d'énergie suite à cette
opération puisque vous dites que le
cours de l'action est passée de 12 à 17
euros et de voilà et donc voilà une
une opération financière en tout cas
pour angie néanmoins pourquoi avoir
retenu un calendrier aussi serré
est ce que cette accélération et de
votre fait
est ce qu'elle est du fait de veolia ou
est ce que l'état a aussi été partie
prenante dans cette accélération du
calendrier
et j'en reviens aussi au rôle de l'état
vis-à-vis d'énergie comment est-ce que
vous concevez l'articulation de votre
activité au sein d'un groupe de grandes
dimensions comme angie avec le le
comment dire le rôle de l'état
actionnaire et comment le l'état
actionnaire dans cette situation nous
revient que vous n'avez pas suivi ces
préconisations peut encore envisager à
partenariat on va dire solide qui prenne
en compte les intérêts de l'un et de
l'autre
merci merci madame la présidente d'abord
avant de revenir aux questions ça va
faire une petite remarque vous avez fait
une remarque à notre présidente sophie
primas tout à l'heure en effet nous
n'avons pas votre connaissance de toutes
les arcanes des grands groupes comme
vous nous ne sommes pas nous mêmes
administrateurs dans dans trois grandes
sociétés mais cela ne nous empêche pas
d'être très attaché à la transparence
notamment quand l'argent public est en
cause et l etat également impliquée je
tenais à vous faire cette petite
remarque j'avais trouvé votre marque à
la limite désobligeantes par rapport à
notre présidente
j'en viens aux questions
[Musique]
la première et directe est toute simple
l'état qui est actionnaire
vous at il demandé de surseoir à
délibérer sur l'offre de veolia eau
pour évaluer l'impact de cette offre au
regard du droit de la concurrence ou
envisager des offres alternatives comme
vous l'avez évoqué tout à l'heure
deuxième question quelles activités vont
faire l'objet d'une mise à distance
entre guillemets dans le cadre de la
stratégie de recentrage du groupe
en quoi consiste précisément cette mise
à distance des introductions en bourse
et des cessions d'actifs ont été évoqués
comment éviter éviter que d'autres
cessions d'actifs séduisent deux
nouveaux induisent de nouvelles
difficultés à l'image de celle qui
touche actuellement suez
dernière question vous l'avez évoqué
tout à l'heure un collègue sophie prix
mais également la crise la crise de
gouvernance qui a touché à une cheville
cette année est elle définitivement
derrière nous avec la désignation de
catherine mcgregor en tant que
directrice générale à compter du 1er
janvier prochain
le président je vous en prie bouton
rouge voilà ces banques quelqu'un
appuyait pour moi non
oui non mais les miens sont moins
sophistiqués non mais je voulais pas du
tout être désobligeant je suis fait jeu
je pense simplement que le rôle des
conseils d'administration de grandes
entreprises privées et souvent méconnus
et la question vous m'avez posé en
disant mais ce que vous pouvez prendre
une décision sur la stratégie en
l'absence d'un directeur général
ma réponse au poc je sais pas mais en
tout cas aujourd'hui la responsabilité
numéro un d'un conseil d'administration
c'est de définir la stratégie
donc oui nous sommes parfaitement
capables de définir une stratégie en
l'absence même d'un directeur général
ça c'est vraiment je voulais rappeler ça
parce que j'ai entendu souvent ce
commentaire fait et d'ailleurs nous
avons fait le choix et c'est pas tout à
fait
ça rit ça me permet de répondre à votre
dernière question sur la crise de
gouvernance après ça je reprendrai
l'ordre nous avons fait le choix chez
angie d'arrêter nos orientations
stratégiques fin juillet avant de
finaliser le recrutement d'un directeur
général qui était annoncé à la fin du
mois de septembre
pourquoi parce que nous voulons un
directeur général qui soit bien en ligne
avec nos orientations stratégiques et
qu'ils soient qui viennent avec un
objectif qui est de les mettre en oeuvre
plutôt que de faire l' inverse qui est
de nommer un directeur général de lui
dire qu'est ce que vous aimeriez faire
comme stratégie revenait dans six mois
on en discute et après on verra ce qu'on
fait non voilà le rôle du conseil c'est
vraiment de définir la stratégie de la
stratégie du groupe et est à nouveau je
ne voulais être désobligeants vis-à-vis
de personnes mais je ne connais pas très
bien les arcanes du travail
parlementaire au sénat et je pense que
il faut il pas inutile de vous rappeler
comment fonctionne notre comment
fonctionne la gouvernance alors pour
reprendre les questions dans l'ordre
elles ont été posées
non on n'a pas un besoin urgent de
liquidités le groupe à j'ai même pas
quel est le chiffre aujourd'hui mais
probablement une trentaine de milliards
d'euros de de trésorerie disponibles ou
mobilisables donc nous avons énormément
de ressources ou nommément de ressources
qui sont qui sont disponibles pour
autant quand on lance un projet ben il
faut essayer de le réaliser dans un
temps relativement raisonnable je
reviendrai plus tard sur le calendrier
alors sur la partie garantie de l'emploi
en fait il ya plusieurs questions dures
qui qui touche à la fois le plan
stratégique d'énergie et puis le sujet
suez
je suis déçu et il est très particulier
c'est la seule situation dans lequel
nous ce que nous avons cédé
c'est une participation financière à
nouveau nous n'avions aucun contrôle
opérationnel sur suez nous consolidons
pas les résultats de suez dans nos
résultats nous recevons simplement un
dividende comme tous les autres
actionnaires et donc nous n'avons pas
d'impact direct sur l'activité du groupe
alors les garanties d'emploi qui ont été
données par veolia elles sont assez
simple elle ne consiste à dire que d'ici
à la fin de l'année 2023 il n'y aura pas
de perte d'emplois sur le périmètre de
suez france tel qu'il est aujourd'hui et
le l'exercice que nous avons fait
avec les équipes de veolia il a consisté
à essayer de repérer par grand périmètre
puisque l'opération est un tout petit
peu complexe ce que sont les effectifs
de suez aujourd'hui
et puis de regarder comment ces
engagements pouvait se mettre en oeuvre
est reportée et nous avons été à la fin
de cet exercice convaincu que
l'engagement avait effectivement du sens
je l' ai dit tout à l'heure dans mon
exposé les administrateurs représentant
les salariés qui siège au conseil
d'énergie était évidemment très attentif
à ce sujet ils ont demandé eux mêmes à
être destinataire des résultats de ses
travaux et ils les ont jugés
convaincants ce qui les a amenés pour
certains à exprimer un soutien à ce
projet pour d'autres à ne prendre à ne
pas prendre part au vote et pour un
quatrième il est resté dans une position
négative vis-à-vis de ce vis-à-vis de ce
projet alors sur les évolutions
concernant angie cette fois ci dans le
périmètre de nos activités de services
ce que nous avons dit c'est que nous
allions mettre sous revue stratégique
c'est-à-dire vous à nous interroger sur
l'avenir d'un ensemble d'activités qui
représente à peu près les deux tiers des
activités de services d' angie donc à
peu près 12 milliards d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires ça représente un cinquième du
total d'énergie qui fait 60 milliards
d'euros de chiffre d'affaires cette
revue stratégique elle est en cours on
donnera un point d'étape à l'occasion de
la présentation de nos résultats la
semaine prochaine donc il est trop tôt
pour savoir ce qu'on sera le résultat
elle peut se traduire effectivement
parce qu'on appelle une une mise à
distance du groupe qui peut être le fait
de constituer un tour de table dans
lequel elle gier est partie prenante
mais ne soit pas seul on pourrait
imaginer qu'un autre acteur viennent
faire l'acquisition de ses activités
services j'y crois pas beaucoup parce
que c'est un un ensemble qui est de
c'est un ensemble qui est de grande
taille
on pourrait aussi imaginer sa mise en
bourse progressive
nous n'avons pas tranché sur ces
différentes hypothèses et je pense que
nous ne trancherons pas avant le début
de l'année prochaine donc c'est vraiment
un exercice qui est en cours et là il
s'agit bien sûr de
aux équipes de nos salariés de nos
métiers de nos clients et donc au
contraire de suez où nous sommes dans
une position d'actionnaire financiers un
petit peu loin de des opérations là
c'est vraiment nous sommes en première
ligne et c'est notre responsabilité
celle du conseil et celle du du
management que de mener à bien ce projet
dans les meilleures conditions possibles
et dans un contexte de dialogue social
enfin le l'objectif qu'on s'est fixé
c'est d'être capable de commencer la
consultation des instances
représentatives du personnel
au début de l'année 2021 alors sur le
gaz les choses sont simples relativement
nous avons aujourd'hui deux activités
qui dans le domaine du gaz en france le
grand transport grt gaz et les activités
de distribution grdf
s'agissant des athées gaz nous avons
déjà au sein du capital de grtgaz des
partenaires la caisse des dépôts et la
cnp ce que nous avons dit dans les
orientations stratégiques que nous
avions annoncé au mois de juillet c'est
que nous envisagions éventuellement la
cession d'une tranche supplémentaire de
capital mais en souhaitant conserver le
contrôle et la consolidation de cet
ensemble ce qui veut dire en pratique on
peut imaginer imaginer céder une dizaine
de pourcent supplémentaire la manière
dont se passent les autres opérations
rendre à ceux ci utile ou pas et donc là
on n'a pas du tout commencé à travailler
sur cette hypothèse mais en tout cas ce
qu'on a dit clairement c'est que nous
voulions rester l'actionnaire
majoritaire
l'actionnaire de contrôle et d'un point
de vue comptable être en situation de
consolider les activités de grt gaz ce
qui veut dire que l'évolution qu'on
envisageait une évolution à la marge sur
cet ensemble là et sur grdf nous
n'envisageons aucune évolutions
capitalistiques donc je dirais que c'est
relativement simple
je me permets d'ailleurs puisque j'ai la
chance d'être devant la représentation
nationale de vous dire que bien sûr
notre préoccupation s'agissant des
infrastructures gazières françaises qui
représente à peu près la moitié des
activités du groupe
c'est la place du gaz dans le mix
énergétique français dans les 30
prochaines années
et nous sommes souvent inquiets de voir
les instances publiques françaises faire
preuve d'un tropisme électrique qui nous
paraît quelques fois excessif une
transition énergétique efficace elle
doit laisser sa place au gaz je vous
rappelle que le jour le plus froid
d'hiver
je vous rappelle pas je vous dis parce
que j'ai découvert ça moi aussi avec un
peu de surprise le jour le plus froid
d'hiver il sort 1,5 fois plus d'énergie
des stockages de gaz d'énergie qu'il
n'en sort de l'ensemble du parc
nucléaire d'edf
cette année en particulier dans lequel
edf un certain nombre de à un certain
nombre de difficultés de disponibilité
de tranche c'est grâce à angie c'est
grâce au gaz que nous pourrons continuer
à nous chauffer dans les jours les plus
froids de cet hiver je referme cette
parenthèse mais pour tous ceux d'entre
vous qui sont attachés aux activités
gazières du groupe
soyons attentifs ne pas créer une
situation dans lequel progressivement
nous soyons amenés à abandonner la
desserte en gaz d'un certain nombre de
territoires parce que nous n'aurions
plus de volumes suffisants à y
transporter je referme la petite
parenthèse mais je ne pouvais pas rater
cette occasion de de vous dire de
partager ce message avec vous alors sur
le deuxième série de questions autour
d'eux est ce le bon moment de vendre
alors si on regarde lors d'un point de
vue simplement financier même si cette
opération et les plus industrielles que
que financières 18 euros c'est le
maximum que c'est la valeur maximum de
l'action suez dans les dents les dix
dernières années juste avant à la fin du
mois de juillet l'action valait 10 euros
après nos annonces et là on va les gens
râlent et 12 en février avant le début
de la crise elle était à 15 je pense
qu'en termes de valeur est en tout cas
c'est ce que nous disent nos c'est ce
que nous disent nos actionnaires nous
avons réalisé une opération qui est
vraiment une bonne opération
et si ce n'était pas le seul critère
mais c'était un critère important pour
nous je
il ya vraiment il ya vraiment pas de
doute que nous n'aurions pas retrouvé il
me faut beaucoup d'imagination pour
pourri mais pour décrire un scénario
dans lequel l'action de suez aurait pu
dépasser dans un avenir prévisible ce
dans un avenir prévisible ce niveau là
alors vous n'avez aussi interrogé sur la
s'agissant des jeans sur les impacts de
de la crise alors ils ont été très
important s'agissant du premier
confinement sur nos activités de
services
pourquoi parce que c'est des activités
qui sont pour partie liée au bâtiment et
aux travaux publics on va surtout au
bâtiment
pourquoi parce que nous sommes souvent
sur les sites de nos clients industriels
qui ont été pour beaucoup fermé à partir
de l'âme de la mi mars
nous avons souffert sur certaines de nos
activités liées à l'énergie mais plutôt
souffert là c'est un petit peu technique
mais parce qu'on avait acheté par avance
des volumes d'énergie que nos clients
n'ont pas consommé
parce que l'activité économique a chuté
fortement dans cette période et nous
avons dû encaisser une forme de pertes
sur ses activités de ses activités de
fourniture
alors bien moins impacté que d'autres
groupes je vous disais que je suis
administrateur de d'airbus airbus a pris
de plein fouet une crise massive
angie a pris une crise qui se traduit
par un impact on aura l'occasion à
nouveau de le commenter dans nos
résultats là la semaine prochaine mais
qui remet pas en cause les fondements du
groupe et sur nos projets
d'investissement la crise a plutôt
montré l'importance des énergies
renouvelables et je pense
qu'effectivement sur nos projets
d'investissement dans les renouvelables
moi j'y vois plutôt je pense que la
crise sera plutôt in fine et on va avoir
un petit petites difficultés cette année
parce qu'un certain nombre de chantiers
ont été arrêtés même dans le domaine des
renouvelables
mais je pense qu'on verra plutôt une une
accélération des investissements dans
les renouvelables dans l'est dans les
prochaines années
donc moi je les en têtes il a pas été
communiquée sous cette forme au marché
donc je vais
je ne vais pas pouvoir vous le partager
avec vous mais c'est un impact visible
mais c'est pas un impact qui ébranle les
fondements du les fondements du groupe
alors 3e série de questions bon sur les
fonds d'investissement mois nouveau
ardien j'aurais été ravi qu'ils nous
fassent une offre enfin le film de
filles barran je crois ne vous l'a pas
d'hier mais juste après car dian et
d'annoncer qu'il abandonnait l'idée de
faire une de faire une offre
moi j'ai rappelé philippe varin pour lui
dire mais pourquoi tu ne leur demande
pas une offre ferme a redit on me dit
qu'ils ont ils sont presque capable de
faire une offre ferme mais ils nous
demandent pour autant six semaines dans
six semaines d'analystes expertise
supplémentaire avant de nous faire une
offre ferme pourquoi est-ce que tu ne
leur demande pas une offre ferme donc
philippe madiba écoute j'appelle la
dirigeante d'art dian et je te rappelle
et il m'a rappelé une heure plus tard
pour dire non ils sont vraiment pas
décidé à faire une offre ferme et tout
l'enjeu il est là enfin tous ceux qui
ont travaillé avec des fonds
d'investissement savent que la seule
manière d'obtenir un prix satisfaisant
bah c'est quand il ya de la concurrence
et hardy en nous disant abandonné
l'offre de veolia et vous verrez on fera
une offre au même prix très franchement
j'y crois pas j'y crois pas un instant
ca sion se retrouve seul face à radiant
le prix qui est à 18 le premier jour il
termine à 14 ou à 15 après six semaines
de six semaines d'analystes donc il faut
forcément qu'on ait une forme de
concurrence et ce qui est vraiment
dommage en revanche c'est que gardien ne
se soit pas mis au travail immédiatement
et là je pense je le dis je sais bien
que le management de suez est passé par
des moments difficiles mais je pense
qu'il nous je pense qu'ils ne se sont
ils n'ont pas réagi suffisamment vite
quand la question de l'avenir de notre
participation s'est posée bertrand camus
a reçu il l'a dit publiquement deux
appels téléphoniques d'antoine frérot
lui disant est ce que tu pense pas qu on
pourrait discuter d'un rapprochement
franchement si le patron de tel ou tel
groupe d'énergie passer un coup de fil
pour me dire ça après avoir accroché lui
avoir dit non je m'équipe immédiatement
de tout ce qu'il faut pour me préparer à
réagir à ce qu'elle à quelle étape
logique suivante d'une d'un appel
téléphonique comme celui ci
je pense que bertrand camus a pas eu
cette réaction et je pense
qu'effectivement ils se sont pas mis au
travail le 1er août pour essayer de
construire une offre alternative en deux
mois on peut construire une offre
alternative logique financière moi je
pardon mais je le crois pas enfin pour
moi ma logique est très industrielle
c'est comment est-ce qu'on a plus
d'argent disponible bon scénar chance et
financiers mais pour construire des
éoliennes pour construire je sais que
tout le monde n'aime pas les éoliennes
ici mais pour construire des des champs
de panneaux photovoltaïques pour
construire des réseaux de chaleur ou des
réseaux de froid dans dans les
territoires que vous représentez c'est
vraiment ce second cherche aujourd'hui
le angie est un groupe qui investit
massivement
on cherche à disposer de plus de
ressources pour investir et sur le
calendrier à nouveau c'est le calendrier
qui a été fixé par veolia moi j'avais
aucune et franchement on a essayé de le
faire bouger enfin moi j'ai essayé
d'obtenir un délai supplémentaire j'ai
finalement obtenu une une petite semaine
de délai supplémentaire je pense que
bruno le maire a passé pas mal de pas
mal de coups de fil et sans doute pour
certains d'entre eux très vigoureux
vis-à-vis de vis-à-vis d'antoine frérot
pour lui dire donnez-nous quinze jours
un mois antoine frérot sur les délais a
été inflexible et je vous invite à lui
poser la question la semaine prochaine
sur pourquoi est ce qu'il a été aussi
inflexible sur sur les délais mais si
lui qui a fixé cette c'est lui qui a
fixé cette ce calendrier et la
responsabilité qui était vraiment très
difficile pour le conseil des mjc aurait
été de renoncer à cette option pour en
espérant qu'il se passerait quelque
chose de mieux
peu après enfin on est dans la situation
dans lequel vous avez intérêt à côté de
chez vous votre voisin vous dit je suis
prêt à vous payer un tel prix plutôt un
bon prix mais j'ai besoin d'une réponse
dans un délai d'un mois parce que sinon
je vais faire autre chose ailleurs
vous avez une décision difficile à
prendre donc le conseil d'énergie face à
cette situation a considéré que sa
responsabilité
c'était bien de c'était bien de prendre
cette offre ton qu'elle était disponible
le rôle de l'état alors de deux choses
sur cette affaire franchement on a
travaillé en très bonne intelligence
avec l'état presque jusqu'à la fin et
moi je salue le rôle de bruno le maire
qui finalement a dit à peu près
là la même chose que moi il faut une
seconde offre et il a appelé au dialogue
et malheureusement il n'a pas été plus
entendu que moi ni sur un sujet ni sur
l'autre et ça je pense qu'on peut le
regretter tous les deux et on a
simplement eu à la fin du processus une
divergence d'appréciation qui a conduit
effectivement à cette position
alors le rôle de l'état actionnaire ça
dépend dans quel ça dépend dans quelle
condition capitalistique il se trouve
quand il est actionnaire comme il l'est
d'edf il a beaucoup de pouvoir quand il
est actionnaire à 22% ou à 30% des
droits de vote il contrôle dans les
fêtes l'assemblée générale donc les
dispositions qui relèvent les décisions
qui relèvent d'une assemblée générale
l'état l'état un mot à dire très
important en revanche au sein du conseil
d'administration y pèse à hauteur de son
hauteur de son poids et ça c'est là
c'est la règle du jeu du droit des
sociétés
que diraient nos autres actionnaires si
nous leur disions vous savez c'est
l'état qui avec ses 22 % fait la loi et
prend les décisions chez chez angie
il considérait à juste titre que leurs
intérêts ne sont pas entendus et le rôle
du conseil c'est bien sûr de faire la
synthèse de ces sept faire la synthèse
de ces éléments et d'essayer de prendre
des décisions dans l'intérêt de la
société et là franchement et je veux pas
vous donner le sentiment d'avoir une
vision très égoïste des très égoïste des
des choses mais cette décision elle est
dans l'intérêt des gee j'emmenais mes
d'intérêt dungey de toutes ses parties
prenantes de ces métiers de ses
activités transformer une participation
financière dans un groupe qui ne nous
rapportent qu'un dividende un groupe et
un groupe avec lequel nous n'avons
jamais réussi à développer des
partenariats opérationnels concret
transformer ça en investissements en
actifs de production d'énergie
renouvelable ou de ou d'infrastructures
qui qui font partie de nos stratégies de
développement c'est vraiment dans
l'intérêt de ces vraiment dans l'intérêt
du groupe
j'en suis j'en suis intimement
j'en suis intimement persuadé sur sur la
dernière série de questions je me suis
exprimé sur sur la première fois que
votre première marque à nouveau je
voulais simplement vous dire que la vie
des affaires évoluent d'ailleurs sur le
rôle des conseils d'administration il va
croissant aujourd'hui les conseils
d'administration ont des responsabilités
essayer d'exercer le mieux possible la
crise de gouvernance oui elle est
derrière nous elle est là reposer alors
tout malheureusement beaucoup de sujets
chez angie prennent et c'est peut-être
d'ailleurs une des c'est peut-être il ya
aussi à la présence de l'état au capital
du groupe qui donne toujours le
sentiment qui a une capacité à aller
chercher une décision un arbitrage au
delà du conseil d'administration même si
sur tous les sujets qu'on a traité cette
année c'est bien le conseil qui a pris
des décisions a pris ses responsabilités
et des décisions infiné mais le fait
qu'un conseil d'administration après un
premier mandat d'un dirigeant de 4 ans
10 il nous faut un style un petit peu
différent pour le mandat suivant bas
c'est assez légitime c'est des choses
qui se passent dans la vie des affaires
assez régulièrement alors elles ont au
cas d'espèce elles ont pris une elles
ont pris une ampleur médiatique pour le
coup un peu inattendu mais ça c'est pas
nécessairement de notre fait mais je
crois qu'aujourd'hui il ya un bon
alignement entre alors au sein du
conseil les total à nos orientations
stratégiques ont été approuvés à
l'unanimité
je pense que catherine mcgregor est un
dirigeant qui vient avec
avec les savoir faire qu'il faut c'est
quelqu'un qui est obsédé par la mise en
oeuvre concrète c'est pas comme elle le
dit avec avec humour une stratégie s'est
jamais que de lancre sur une feuille de
papier ou un transparent qui est projeté
dans une sur un écran ce qui compte
c'est la manière dont on la met en
oeuvre et donc yab énormément de choses
à faire dans les prochaines années chez
angie et je pense qu'il ya un très bon
alignement entre le conseil et et notre
nouvelle directrice générale sur
l'avenir nos activités de service je me
suis exprimé il a quelques instants sur
sur le sujet et je pense que c'est un
sujet qu'on regarde avec beaucoup
d'attention et beaucoup de
responsabilités peut-être pour
un dernier point à ses activités de
services que j'ai essayé de vous décrire
tout à l'heure c'est quelque chose qui
ressemble beaucoup à un autre groupe
français qui s'appelle spi donc ce qu'on
fait c'est vraiment ce qui va y avoir
dans cet ensemble la cde ce que ce sont
des activités très proche de celle que
font spi ou vinci énergie si ce n'est
que l'ensemble aura à peu près de deux
fois la taille de deux fois la taille de
ce pic
voilà je pense que j'ai fait le tour des
se plaisent dans un faire un petit
switch de présidence avec mon collègue
daniel grémillet parce que je dois aller
en séance je suivrai la suite
moi j'ai une demande de parole de me
guillaume chevrollier oui merci monsieur
le président monsieur pierre madiot
joueurs sortir du sujet veolia suez et
profitez de votre présence pour avoir
votre perception à l'issue de la crise
sanitaire vous quelles leçons vous en
tirez en tant qu'administrateur de
différents grands groupes
on l'avait dit et président d'un conseil
d'administration quelles leçons vous en
tirez à titre personnel et comment angie
a géré la crise même si vous en avez un
petit peu parlé sur la comment vous le
groupe a traversé la crise et vous avez
parlé de cette crise sanitaire qui peut
être un facteur d'accélération dans la
transition écologique
comment vous percevez le plan de relance
dans ce domaine là et comment angie va
s'inscrire dans ce plan de relance
récemment vous avez inauguré un centre
de recherche le angie lab criigen on
sait que la recherche et développement
et est fondamental pour pour permettre
de la compétitivité et permettent la
transition énergétique est ce que vous
pouvez nous parler de ce laboratoire
et qu'est ce que vous en attendez un
précisément traduction concrète
merci ce que je propose c'est qu'on
alterne donc il y avait fabien gay merci
monsieur le président sur le présent je
m'excuse par avance les jeux devraient
aussi me rendre en séance je ne pourrais
pas entendre votre réponse mais je
l'écouterai avec plaisir donc deux
questions simples c'est le rôle de
l'état nous avait répondu c'est un
actionnaire parmi d'autres et vous avez
travaillé avec eux jusqu'à quasiment la
fin mais quand même on a un premier
ministre qui nous a dit que c'était un
bon rapprochement on à bruno le maire
qui a dit plus tôt l' inverse et on a
des administrateurs de l'état qui se
sont abstenus soit ont voté contre
et moi je suis pas tout suivi sur je ne
connais pas tous les règlements des
conseils d'administration mais je me
souviens bien
pendant la loi pacte quand on a autorisé
l'état pour notre part nous avons voté
comme mais à descendre sous les 30 3% et
bruno le maire je me rappelle très bien
nous avait dit ne vous inquiétez pas
nous aurons 22% des parts mais 30 % des
votes
nous resterons actionnaire majoritaire
mais nous aurons la gaude golden share
qui nous permettra au chaos de bloquer
s'il y avait un problème ou une décision
que qui nous conviendrait pas donc je
voudrais savoir pourquoi ce process n'a
peu ou pas fonctionné et la deuxième
question monsieur le président c'est
qu'on a entendu les
le président de suez et aussi les
salariés nous dire que ce rapprochement
pourrait causer quatre à cinq mille
pertes d'emploi sur notre territoire et
vous nous dites on a étudié les choses
avec véolia et on assure que jusqu'en
il n'y aura pas de perte en réalité
d'emploi donc je voudrais savoir et la
dernière je pense que c'est le premier
étage d'une fusée du démantèlement d'
angie et vous l'avez à peine évoquée
mais de scinder l'entreprise en deux
nuits au angie et new solution est tenu
aux solutions de le faire entrer en
bourse
c'est exactement le même procédé qui a
encore aujourd'hui avec edf et le projet
recule donc quelle garantie de ne pas
voir le groupe mgi de démontrer par ce
procédé
voilà je vous remercie un bien comme
vous voulez oui moi j'en ai encore
martha de sidrac j'ai demandé à paroles
et après après soi merci monsieur le
président merci de me donner l'occasion
de poser une question monsieur clamadieu
vous nous avez effectivement présenté
des éléments de la stratégie d'un gic
est une très belle entreprise française
on n'en doute pas et je pense que nous
aurons évidemment l'occasion de vous
retrouver à d'autres occasions à
d'autres d'autres auditions mais en fait
aujourd'hui moi le sujet qui m'intéresse
c'est que ça concerne en fait les
questions que je vais vous poser trois
belles entreprises françaises dont kanji
bien sûr veolia et suez l'une veut
acheter une seconde la seconde ne
souhaite pas se faire à se faire acheter
et la troisième cède ses parts de l'une
des deux autres
donc tout ça en fait nous amène quand
même un certain nombre de questions
auxquelles vous avez déjà répondu pour
une grande partie dans vos propos
liminaire malgré tout vous avez fait par
vous même du regret de la situation
actuelle que vous vivez comme nous je
suppose de manière je vais pas dire
peut-être douloureuse mais
manière pas très confortable
certainement et vous avez également
rappelé malgré tout dans vos propos
liminaire que angie aujourd'hui n'avait
pas en réalité une nécessité urgente de
céder ses parts de suez
bien que vous ayez présenter évidemment
tous vos sujets tous vos projets
d'investissements que angie souhaite
faire à l'avenir
donc du coup ma question va être très
simple très rapide voire naïve mais je
souhaite vous l'a reposé monsieur le
président est ce que la décision d'un
gie aujourd'hui est irrévocable contenu
de ce contexte qui en fait un pacte
trois belles entreprises je le rappelle
qui sont toutes les trois françaises et
auquel nous sommes tous très attachés
dans nos territoires vous avez vu les
interrogations voire les inquiétudes de
certaines de nos collectivités et vous
avez également du bien évidemment être
sensible à la situation de crise
sanitaire qui aujourd'hui quand même un
point prégnant dans l'opinion publique
et derrière ces trois belles entreprises
il y à des hommes et des femmes qui
forcément seront à un moment donné
impacté par les décisions quelles
qu'elles soient
donc est ce que aujourd'hui votre
décision en tant que président du
conseil d'administration d'hadji la
décision est vraiment et irrévocable
donc est ce que vous envisagez
éventuellement d'autres sorties merci je
vais aussi yves bouloux qui souhaitent
intervenir
oui merci messieurs les présidents des
commissions monsieur le président le
tribunal judiciaire de paris saisi en
référé par les comités sociaux et
économiques du groupe suez a ordonné la
suspension de l'opération résultant de
l'offre d'acquisition par véolia des
actions suez détenu par angie ainsi que
l'offre publique d'achat prévue dans la
foulée
sais-tu cette suspension a été décidée
tant que les comités sociaux économiques
de suez et suez aux france
à l'origine de la procédure n'auront pas
été informées et consultées
je cite sur les décisions je cite aussi
prise si votre participation n'a pas
vocation à être pérenne
on peut le comprendre pour autant
pourquoi avoir choisi de faire appel et
ne pas vous être conformer à la décision
du tribunal
pourquoi serait-il ne serait-il pas
possible d' informer et consulter les
comités sociaux économiques comme l'a
exigé le tribunal judiciaire pour le
droit des salariés
lesquels d'ailleurs doivent être assez
inquiet je donne la parole à monsieur
favreau gilbert
la plupart de ceux qui sont présents
commence à connaître avec effectivement
3 3 groupes qui sont concernés qui dans
ce groupe angie est sensiblement le plus
important en chiffre d'affaires mais
trois groupes qui sont des entreprises
connues qui d'ailleurs se connaissent de
longue de longue date puisque gdf suez
était à l'époque le résultat d'une
première tentative dopé à hostile d'une
société italienne
donc on se connaît bien dans cette
maison et moi ce qui me trouble et c'est
la question que je me posais parce que
mes rejoint des questions qui ont déjà
été posés c'est le rôle de l'état ou
d'un certain nombre d'actionnaires au
moment du vote de la session sur la
cession des actions et angie avait au
lien puisqu'il clairement l'état aurait
très bien pu me semble-t-il et si les
renseignements que je possède sont
exactes
l'état aurait aurait pu avec les droits
de vote qu'il possédait aurait pu disons
surseoir à vous faire en sorte qu'un
vote positif sur la vente ne soient pas
pris au moment du conseil
d'administration il ne l'a pas fait donc
moi la question et c'est à dire c'est
peut-être pure curiosité intellectuelle
mais ça ça montre que quand même dans ce
dossier la position de l'état et
quelquefois un petit peu surprenante
mais ça ne serait pas la première fois
vous vous disiez je crois récemment tout
cas c'est vu ça dans la presse que
l'état est certes actionnaires
d'entreprises mais que ça n'est reste
pas angie n'est pas une entreprise
publique et je partage parfaitement
votre point de vue donc la question
comment expliquez vous expliquez vous qu
effectivement alors qu'il avait près de
35% des droits de vote
et bien finalement l'état n'ait pas
voulu prendre une position qui soit une
position claire qui aurait permis
effectivement d'aller vers ces délais
qui sont eux demandé eux à côté de moi
clairement il y a de la part de l'état
un consentement tacite à ma vision dans
ma vision des choses à la cession des
actions de ji à veolia simplement je
vais être obligé aussi moi de vous
quitter parce que j'ai rendez vous chez
chez le président du sénat donc je vais
demander à martin de ces drogues de
venir à ma place merci bien il ya la
question aussi d'olivier y est mannequin
et puis je crois que nous aurons aussi
une question en visio peu docile vient
de le président que je vous propose
c'est de prendre l'ensemble des
questions qui ça vous gêne pas oui mais
rivière merci monsieur le président
monsieur le président du conseil
d'administration d' angie j'avais une
question qui me turlupine est plus tout
à l'heure quand on regarde votre
parcours brillant si on regarde vous
avez repris un moment la direction de la
radio qui était dans une situation quasi
faillite à l'époque et vous l'avait
amené à une entreprise qui est devenue
non seulement rentable mais également un
des leader dans son domaine et laouzas
et fait preuve de toutes les meilleures
compétences dans ce domaine et vous avez
ensuite enclenché avec l'opa amicale de
solvay sur rhodia qui a été un exemple
en la matière et qui a débouché sur un
groupe international
exceptionnel et dont vous avez pris
assez rapidement la présidence vous avez
su amener rhodia d'une situation très
difficile à une situation brillante qui
a était enviée par certains notamment
par se lever et vous avez su accompagner
une opa amicale et qui sait pour le coup
excellemment bien passé et je me pose la
question
en tant que président d n'diaye donc
actionnaire très important de suez
vous nous avez expliqué qu'à un moment
vous aviez dit à bertrand camus voilà il
faudra attendre un certain moment que
soit on retire entre guillemets nobi du
l'actionnariat de suez soit qu on
augmente notre part et puis vous avez
dit la même chose à monsieur varin et je
me pose la question pourquoi à ce moment
là vous n'avez pas saisi l'opportunité
qui vous était fait en tant que
actionnaire très important du groupe
suez d'accompagner le groupe suez dans
votre volonté de vous retirer du capital
de suez
plutôt que du jour au lendemain leur
dire voilà on retire nobi et finalement
alors j'excuse l'expression qui a un peu
caricatural mais jeter en pâture suez à
n'importe quel investisseur il se trouve
que pour le cas c'est véolia et ne pas
avoir pendant un certain temps préparer
le groupe suez à cette modification a
c'est très très du capital il reste
encore deux questions pour la commission
aménagement du territoire
rapidement jean michel ould dah oui
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
président donc la vente des parts de
suez à vous donnez donc les moyens
d'agir pour accélérer votre votre plan
stratégique le groupe
angie bien évidemment ce sont aussi des
implantations territoriales et vous
savez que dans les territoires on
commence parfois un peu sentir le vent
du boulet quand il ya des projets
stratégiques qui se mettent en oeuvre
donc je prends je prends deux exemples
on a bien compris que haendel par
exemple été dans le périmètre endel
c'est quand même 140 implantations en
france même si c'est un chiffre
d'affaires de 750 millions d'euros c'est
peu par rapport à ce que vous avez cités
j'ai bien compris également mais c'est
quand même six mille salariés
j'ai bien compris à travers également
que d'autres activités que vous avez
cités que vous allez pouvoir le
confirmer que ce qu'on appelait
autrefois angie cofely est maintenant
une j solution serait aussi dans le
périmètre ses douze mille salariés donc
la question que je me pose elle est très
simple c'est d'abord quel niveau
d'exigence vous aurez par rapport à des
futurs acquéreurs et quel dialogue
vous allez engager avec les territoires
s'il vient de noël normalement on la
voit pas bien on doit l'entendre et
ensuite anne catherine sylviane si ça
marche pas une catherine en attendant
que le son on revienne
merci à catherine loisier merci monsieur
le présent elle en fait trois petites
questions assez précises
d'abord à ce que monsieur le président
il serait possible de disposer du procès
verbal de ce conseil d'administration du
5 octobre
est ce que les sénateurs pour un avoir
accès ou en est en fait la procédure
suit aussi être que j'en ai parlé de ce
que j'étais pas là au tout début mais où
on est là que la procédure suite au
référé qui étaient déposés par les
comités sociaux d'entreprise est-ce que
puisqu'on annoncé dans les médias que le
très bien judiciaire suspend dès
l'acquisition donc en fait quel effet
sur sur la procédure actuelle et et
j'entends également parlé d'un
signalement au parquet financier donc
qu'en est il est tout réformer une
dernière question pour la commission
aménagement du territoire monsieur hervé
gillé oui merci très rapidement puisque
mes collègues précédents ont pesé aussi
d'excellentes questions mais pour aller
jusqu'au bout et effectivement de sujets
la cession porte donc sur 3 4 milliards
d'euros
on regarde votre réserve financière que
vous avez cités de 30 milliards d'euros
c'est effectivement un impact très
relatif donc même par rapport à votre
plan stratégique d'investissement vous
n'aviez pas forcément besoin de cette
somme là donc est ce que vraiment votre
décision se résume simplement à
l'intérêt des 18 euros
puisque il vous semble que la
conjoncture était effectivement très
favorable à ce niveau là vous n'aviez
pas stratégiquement besoin de vendre
effectivement cette participation et
vous l'avez souligné cette participation
n'avait qu'un caractère financier et non
pas opérationnel donc quand on regarde
votre autre plan stratégique pour vous
dégagez de certaines activités vous
recentrer sur notre coeur de métier
il n'y avait pas non plus cette
nécessité donc on peut s'interroger bien
c'est pas si sylvain de noël nous a
rejoints sinon j'avais moi même aussi
des questions la première ce président
est ce que vous pouvez nous confirmer
effectivement que des dirigeants de qui
a eu aucun échange avec les dirigeants
de veolia entre le mois de mai mois de
septembre une question toute simple
autre point qui me semble nécessaire
d'aborder aussi c'est qu'elles sont
précisément les solutions clients dont
angie envisage la mise en en distance
pour ne pas dire la session quand
j'évoque cette question-là ses solutions
clients ainsi cédé non elle bien aucun
lien avec le secteur de l'énergie dans
contraire nous serions dans une
situation tout à fait paradoxale où
angie ambitionnerait de devenir un
leader de la transition énergétique tout
en cédant ses activités fixe et
d'efficacité énergétique réalisés au
profit des entreprises des collectivités
territoriales ça c'est une première
question le deuxième question mais là tu
as été un peu abordée par mon collègue
tout à l'heure mais je voudrais la
développer s'ils m'y autorisaient aller
plus loin puisque le sénat effectivement
est très dans les différents textes a
été très sensible sur le dossier de la
transition énergétique est pour nous la
clairvoyance sur une gouvernance et des
capitaux suffisants pour promouvoir le
verdissement du marché du gaz
première question vous savez combien le
sénat est attaché à la promotion du
biogaz est de l'hydrogène gazeux pour
lequel il a fait adopter des
dispositions non négligeable dans le
texte de la loi énergie climat et dans
la loi a zappé
l'autre enjeu c'est celui de la
souveraineté je reviens sur ce qui a été
dit par mon collègue sa souveraineté
énergétique autrement dit le maintien
sous contrôle français
on sait que le domaine énergétique non
un enjeu stratégique
et puis la dernière question ska
concerne angie sur l'évolution du mix
énergétique européen
electrabel la filiale d'énergie qui
exploite la plupart des centrales
nucléaires belges elles représentent la
moitié de la production d'extraits de ce
pays
vous avez un rôle majeur dans ce pays il
est confronté à la sortie du nucléaire
d'ici 2025 pour s'y préparer
elle installe notamment des centrales à
gaz
quel est votre point de vue sur cette
situation et quel est son impact sur
l'activité du groupe
alors j'appelle une dernière fois s'il
vient de noël au cas où
manifestement la liaison ne se fait pas
marthe est une application
merci plus de demandes de noms mais je
crois que monsieur le président vous
avez beaucoup là bon je vais essayer
l'intérêt que quoi ces deux conditions
sine qua non merci monsieur le président
monsieur le président se faisait des
regards t'entends bien vas-y on n'entend
plus voilà oui c'est bon oui donc à u2
les deux groupes représentent 60% du
marché privé de l'eau et de
l'assainissement en france la part
restante se divisant entre la saur et
des entreprises de taille plus modeste
dans ces circonstances vous comprendrez
que les élus locaux et d'attraper les
usagers se montre très inquiet face à la
naissance de ce nouveau géant qui a mené
ce que ford dégrader les conditions de
concurrence dans un marché déjà très
monopolistique
il y à la question du plie de services
mais aussi la question de la qualité du
service qui se posent également puisque
face à l'affaiblissement de la
concurrence la pression sur le
concessionnaire sera forcément moindre
face à ces risques de nombreux élus
risquent eux de choisir finalement de
reprendre la gestion de l'eau en régie
ce qui pourrait de fait conduire un
affaiblissement de votre groupe
ma question est simple quelle garantie
pouvez vous aujourd'hui nous donner et
donner à ces nombreux élus inquiets face
à l'avenir pour essayer d'effacer leur
crainte je vous remercie
je me lance dans les réponses alors
effectivement là on couvre des champs
très très très très vaste donc je vais
essayer d'être relativement bref pour
les leçons de leçons de la crise
sanitaire moi j'en vois plusieurs je
pense que comme tout le monde je suis
par maman effaré de l'impact de cette
crise et de l'âme et de la vulnérabilité
qu'elle fait apparaître dans nos
sociétés c'est assez incroyable de voir
par exemple que tous les échanges entre
pays sont réduits en termes de personnes
en tout cas sont réduits alors alors
plus simple expression
nos modes de travaux de travail sont
complètement différent j'étais hier à la
tour angie on devait avoir 20 personnes
dans une tour qui en accueille
habituellement 3000 et je pourrais
multiplier les exemples un peu
anecdotique donc je pense que notre
monde est vulnérable et le prochain
grand risque c'est de changement
climatique et je suis très heureux de
voir que les gouvernements l'union
européenne ont effectivement réagi comme
je le suggérais comme d'autres personnes
j'étais pas très original dans ses
commentaires en avril ou mai en disant
il faut absolument qu'on tire de cette
crise le une conviction qu'il faut se
presser il faut rendre notre monde plus
résilient à la prochaine et moi je suis
vraiment persuadé qu'à prochaine c'est
la crise climatique
donc ça c'est là la première leçon est
extrêmement forte qu'on doit tirer la
seconde c'est qu'on a quand même capable
de réagir très vite face à des dangers
enfin le jeu j'ai pris l'exemple un peu
sinistre d'une tour presque vide à la
défense je pourrais vous dire de manière
un peu plus positive qu'on a une seconde
fois mis probablement quarante mille
personnes en télétravail chez angie en
l'espace de 24 ou 48 heures et qu'on
arrive à le faire avec un impact sur
notre qualité de service qui est voisine
de zéro alors je dis pas que c'est un
mode de fonctionnement de l'entreprise
qui est aux petits malins loin s'en faut
je dois posent d'énormes difficultés
mais en revanche on assure la sécurité
d'approvisionnement de nos clients on
est sur toute la toute la relation
client je disais tout à l'heure qu'on
avait 11 millions de clients en france
on est capable face à des situations
exceptionnelles de prendre des mesures
extrêmement fortes ça c'est un élément
un petit peu plus
c'est un élément un petit peu plus
encourageants mais vraiment je crois
qu'il faut que je crois qu'il faut que
nous nous préparions à 7 à cette crise
climatique pour en atténuer les impacts
dire réduire le phénomène lui-même mais
aussi se préparer à rendre notre monde
plus résilient les constantes de temps
sont très différentes à la crise
climatique elle va mettre quelques
décennies à se cristalliser la crise
sanitaire elle s'est cristallisé en
quelques en quelques semaines mais il
faut il faut pas que ça nous donne un
sentiment de le sentiment que on a le
temps pour pour s'y préparer au
contraire je pense que c'est une vraie
urgence à une urgence qui est cette
crise là c'était climatique elle est
irréversible ce qui n'est pas le cas de
je l'espère de la crise sanitaire
transition énergétique donc priorité on
l'a dit moi je
je pense qu'on a vu on voit beaucoup de
choses dans le plan de relance qui nous
conviennent bien de mesures très court
terme est très immédiates autour de
l'efficacité énergétique dans les dents
les bâtiments jusqu'à des choses de plus
long terme sur par exemple
l'introduction de l'hydrogène c'est je
trouve qu'il ya je trouve qu'il ya un
bon équilibre alors qu'est ce qu'on y
trouve pas puisque c'est probablement là
la règle du jeu de dire aussi que le
vert il n'est pas complètement plein on
aurait aimé voir une accélération des
développements dans le biogaz
vous avez rappelé que cette maison était
attentive à ce type de projet moi je
suis très convaincu que le biogaz à
court terme
l'hydrogène à moyen terme sont des
éléments très importants du mix
énergétique
ils ont par ailleurs des effets sur
l'aménagement du territoire qui sont peu
qu'ils sont importants et qu'il faut
être capable de faire valoir on est dans
un on est un moment où l'état a pas tout
à fait assez de ressources pour faire
face à tous les projets de développement
de biogaz qui ce qu'ils sont en train de
se consolider sur le territoire c'est
vrai que j'aurais pu espérer que le plan
de relance contiennent un volet qui
permettent de faire face à toutes ces
idées et opportunités même commentaire
d'ailleurs sur les énergies
renouvelables le
éolien et solaire le plan de relance ne
comporte pas non plus d'accélération
mais il ya une dynamique suffisamment
forte probablement qui est engagée pour
qu'on n'ait pas d'inquiétude quant au
fait que quand au fait que les choses
puissent retombées recherche et
développement je suis en ce haut conseil
d'administration d' angie qui dit qu'on
n'en fait pas assez probablement parce
que je viens d'un métier là la chimie
dans lequel on une entreprise dépensé 3
4% de son chiffre d'affaires en
recherche et développement
on est à des chiffres bien inférieurs
mais ce qu'on fait dans le centre de
recherche que vous évoquez qu'on a que
j'ai inauguré dans le nord de paris il
ya quelques semaines c'est effectivement
des travaux autour des gaz renouvelables
biogaz bio gaz hydrogène mais aussi
autour de du développement du digital le
digital qui s'applique dans beaucoup
d'endroits il nous permet aussi de mieux
gérer nos propres installations de
production transport d'énergie permet de
mieux gérer l'énergie chez nos clients
et donc c'est un ensemble de travaux qui
qui contribuent à faire de nous un
leader dans ces problématiques de
transition énergétique mais je pense
qu'il faut probablement qu'on en fasse
un peu plus ce jeu superbement frappé de
la modestie de nos efforts dans le
domaine de l'hydrogène par exemple des
biogaz je pense qu'il ya encore beaucoup
de cheveux beaucoup de chants à
investiguer beaucoup de progrès à faire
et je pense qu'il faut qu'on soit il
faut qu'on soit probablement encore plus
déterminé pour avoir échangé beaucoup
sur ce sujet avec catherine mcgregor je
pense qu'elle partage lots 6 est elle
aussi ce souci de développer plus de
savoir-faire ou de technologies qui nous
appartiennent chez angie alors que
souvent on est plutôt un ensemblier on
va chercher des morceaux de solutions
ici ou là et on les assemble mais je
crois qu'il faut que dans certains cas
nous sachions développer nos propres
solutions technologiques alors le rôle
de l'état chez angie l'état a pas de
golden share c'est je pense que ce qu'il
faut bien comprendre c'est que quand
vous avez 30% du capital d'une société
dans la pratique vous contrôlez
l'assemblée générale
parce que vous avez généralement un peu
plus de 50% des actionnaires qui sont
qui sont représentés à l'assemblée
générale donc si vous avez 30 % bas
l'arithmétique est assez simple vous
avez là vous avez la majorité en
revanche est en bonne gouvernance vous
ne contrôlez pas le conseil
d'administration c'est d'ailleurs la
situation que nous avions chez suez nous
avions 32 % du capital de suez nous
contrôlions l'assemblée générale
de fait on avait la majorité quand
l'assemblée se réunissaient pour autant
nous avions deux administrateurs nous
avons d'ailleurs toujours deux
administrateurs sûr je sais pas combien
je crois qu'ils sont seize ou dix sept
chez suez donc on a une voix qui est à
la hauteur de ses qui est à la hauteur
de cette représentation dans le conseil
il n'y a pas de golden share dire qu'il
ya pas l'état pas de droits spécifiques
qui lui permettrait de comme il en a
dans des sociétés liées par exemple à la
défense nationale donc nous sommes
ensuite soumis au code de commerce dans
de la manière la plus simple et direct
et à nouveau un axe enfin l'état comme
n'importe quel autre actionnaire ne peut
pas dire au conseil d'administration
retarder une décision sur un sujet
prenez une décision de telle ou telle
nature l'état et est un actionnaire
comme les autres actionnaires importants
et mais pas un actionnaire pas un
actionnaire qui fait la pluie et le beau
temps si je peux employer ce terme
une fois que j'ai dit ça mon rôle de
président du conseil il est bien sûr de
trouver un alignement et sur beaucoup de
sujets on trouve cet alignement sur
celui ci on a constaté qu'il y avait au
moment de la prise de décisions qu'il y
avait des positions qui étaient qui
était effectivement différentes et qui
ont conduit à qui ont conduit à ce que
j'ai décrit à ce que j'ai décrit tout à
l'heure sur l'impact emploi donc le dans
le
très de manière assez directe à nos
administrateurs salariés nous demandent
dans le cadre des projets que nous avons
aujourd'hui finalement de leur concéder
les mêmes garanties que celles que
veolia était prête à est prête à
concéder dans le cadre d'un
rapprochement avec suez s'est pas
complètement surprenant comme position
donc même si on n'est pas encore au
stade où on ait besoin de parler de ce
sujet puisque on est encore en train
d'étudier la forme que pourrait prendre
l'organisation de cette nouvelle société
et comment est-ce qu'elle pourrait
prendre une forme d'autonomie vis-à-vis
d'énergie mais je pense que le moment
venu nous serons bien sûr amené à
prendre des garanties comme on le fait
traditionnellement
et je pense que là on sera
particulièrement attentif parce que nos
différentes parties prenantes le second
démantèlement d' angie moi je c'est
évidemment pas le c'est évidemment pas
l'objectif et je ne suis pas sûr que de
se recentrer sur les métiers qui sont au
coeur de des savoir faire du groupe soit
les prémices d'un démantèlement
angie dans sa dans sa culture dans son
adn comme on dit c'est un groupe
industriel c1
c'est un groupe qui est à l'aise dans la
le développement de grands projets dans
la construction de grandes installations
dans leur exploitation dans le cadre de
contrats à très long terme
les activités de services qu'on évoque
le dans le dans l'une de nos filiales
que cp lineo j'ai pas les chiffres sur
toute la taille moyenne du contrat ses
10000 euros
voilà pour cette audition au sénat du
président du conseil d'administration d'
angie
une audition qui a porté sur le rachat
de suez par veolia pour créer un géant
mondial dans le secteur de la gestion de
l'eau et des déchets c'est la fin de
cette émission merci de l'avoir suivi
continu à suivre l'actualité politique
et parlementaire sur notre site internet
publicsenat.fr
je vous souhaite une très bonne journée
sur public sénat